hello everyone
in this video i am going to have a
discussion with the creator the original
creator of symbolic python dr omri
cherty symbolic python or simba in short
is a library of open source programs
written in pure python it can be used
for a number of different purposes
algebra solving different kinds of
equations linear simultaneous equations
differential equations it can be used
for calculus for linear algebra in
symbolic form and a bunch of other
things like number theory it is used
mainly by scientists engineers and
certainly mathematicians i for one use
it regularly in my courses of elasticity
and mechanics of solids my students also
use them regularly while doing their
term projects in fact simba makes our
life
in elasticity and mechanics of solids
a lot easier
on the development side senpai is being
actively developed by a growing
community a lot of whom are indian
students and many of whom have been
directly mentored and trained by dr
andre chiarde beyond sempai andre is
also involved with a number of other
exciting projects about which we are
going to have a discussion what follows
is a long and elaborate conversation
with andre i hope you will enjoy this
conversation as much as i did
hello andre uh a very warm welcome to my
small youtube channel
and uh thanks a lot for spending your
time to be here
hi jeevan thank you for having me hello
so we'll start off with the questions
immediately um
so andre uh
when did you first start learning how to
program photos your first programming
language and if you remember what was
the first program that you wrote
so my first i
learned the program when i was i started
when i was seven i think my dad was
teaching
seven yeah oh my god teaching me how to
program and i think my first program was
incrementing a variable
and it was in pascal uh turbo pascal to
be so
exact okay
i've never touched pascal in my entire
life
the first thing i started learning was
uh basic i think many people from my
generation they started learning in
basic in this school
okay so next question is you are the
creator of sempai
right and senpai as far as i understand
is written in pure python
uh yes
so
when did you first start learning python
and what was your experience with it
like initially so that uh like you felt
an intrinsic appeal to it that you
actually went ahead and used python to
create something new altogether
so i think uh i first learned python
while i was still at high school i think
it was in the early 2000s i don't
remember exactly when
and what i liked about python is that it
was a language that was
a general purpose language it was not
tied to any particular application such
as
let's say mathematica or or
matlab or only develop web development
or scripting it was just meant as a
language
that can be used for anything and it's
open source easy to install and it was
easy to write extensions either pure
python libraries or even see
libraries or fortune libraries and and
wrap it so that
you can publish your code your library
and then people can easily use it um
from an interactive environment
so was it like was it like a programming
culture in your school
something
completely on your own
it was completely on my own all right
discovered
so uh you you mentioned uh i think in
passing mathematical right so that was
actually my next question that what was
it exactly that motivated you to start
the symbolic python project the same
pipe project so did something like
mathematical map will have any influence
on your thinking
yes so i used maple and vet america and
matlab
at high school and kind of late i was
having some internship at university and
you know that's those are the tools that
they used
i like mathematica a lot
it's just that i wanted to be able to
tweak the algorithms so i wanted to have
access to the source code of let's say
the algorithms how it computes things so
i can tweak it and also so that i can
write a script or kind of an application
if you will that uses mathematica as a
library
and that's open source where people can
just download it and run it on their
hardware of their computers
without any issues
and
with mathematica you cannot do it
because if i distribute my script
somebody they have to buy a license so
it's a whole process before they can run
it but with python all they have to do
is just literally download um you know
and if they use linux they can just run
it right away and so the barrier is just
much lower in python um
that's kind of i think the main kind of
advantage that i liked and also as i
mentioned i think the language is
slightly nicer i
i like the python languages very simple
language very quick to learn
has very few
ways that you can you know be surprised
as a beginner with python
well with mathematica you know it has
all kinds of corner cases where you have
to kind of get used to it
ah thanks so uh this was on the on the
more on the
on the environment side of things uh
purely on the mathematical side where
was there some kind of a motivation that
oh
uh yeah maybe you were trying to do
something in mathematics or maple and
then you felt that you perhaps if only
you could tweak the source code a little
bit but you couldn't and then you
thought that what if you if you just uh
started the whole thing from the
groundwork in a completely open fashion
you could lay the groundwork yourself
tweak it as you wish
something like on those lines
yes um
so one of the first well
so i'm
i was studying physics at the time and
so
one of the first kind of places where i
really wanted to have something like
senpai is
when you
you know do general relativity and you
are trying to derive the i think the
solution from
the metric for it from the unstance
equations
until it takes you know especially if
it's the first time you're doing it it
takes like three hours of derivations on
the paper and it's all relatively very
simple just a symbolic four bar four
four matrix and you differentiate pretty
much and you know and just add terms
together so it's just something really
simple
but but if you lay by hand just takes
forever you can this particular thing
you can do in mathematica but
what i wanted to do is have a python
script so that i can
have the matrix symbolic matrix as a
python variable and be able to print it
and kind of play with it
from python i mean
you know mathematica is perfectly fine
find product i think you can do any
anything simple i can do and
anything you know you you know many
people use it all the time but i think i
just kind of like the python i like i
like that as i mentioned that you can
don't need any license it's all open
source all available for me or others to
easily play with so that was i guess my
kind of initial motivation and of course
you know as a physics student you know
so much stuff that uh just is asking for
for being automated and
making it accessible from python
so
it was a similar sort of experience for
me
except that i used what you had what you
and other contributors had created so
back in 2019 i was teaching a course on
elasticity here at iit kharagpur and
so there was this
entire derivation uh in 2d polar
coordinates uh so where we had to go
from the
from the cartesian system to the the 2d
polar coordinates uh and the entire
laplacian had to be derived in terms of
the r theta coordinates
now now we have a very famous book in
elasticity it's like an all-time classic
uh by emotion goodyear so all the steps
are mentioned there but in a very uh
soviet fashion they just skip all the
steps in between they give the very
tears kind of
results now
i did then that thing by hand it turned
out to be 10 pages long
now i could not do that on board i mean
i could do that i would have to invest
two weeks off my class hours
uh so i thought that what if i just try
to do it in symbols like see for myself
i could do it it turned out like i could
do it very quickly so i thought why not
just demonstrate it in class for the
kicks of it i demonstrated and then the
feedback was so nice then that i
continued to use symbolic python for the
rest of the course and then in the
subsequent years i have actually went on
to encourage my students to do their
term projects also with symbolic python
so that makes the course a little less
boring
uh
and i think we have all benefited so
thanks a lot actually as a teacher
myself yes i mean you're kind of coming
from the same you know it's effectively
differential geometry whether it's uh
yeah
battery or not flies the same thing it's
just some kind of effective matrices and
you have to transform from one
coordinate system to another and so it's
a lot of work yeah
and it's you know people used to do it
by hand that was the only way but it's
just one of these one of the things that
as a student when
you really want to learn it you really
kind of have to do it yourself that's
the only way to learn it uh but because
it's so tedious it just is very
discouraging but if you can
ideally if you can just uh take a
symbolic package like in pi and just
write the code yourself so that you know
exactly what the steps are but
automating them i think that's the best
way to learn and it's a lot more fun
let's say with the middle relativity you
can change the metric and see how the
equations change
see how
uh things change and just kind of very
quickly you don't have to wait three
hours and make a mistake and then just
takes forever to track it back uh so you
can kind of play with it and really get
good experience and realize oh the ideas
are super simple it's just
you know the mechanism you know to do
these transformations are
it's a very straightforward very simple
you know idea it's just uh tedious
so uh thanks for actually
mentioning that because i i had noticed
that uh this tediousness or the tedium
of actually going through that algebra
and
the the demotivation that arises from
just making a sign mistake here uh or
maybe a sine theta becomes acoustic or
somewhere because of a certain lapse of
concentration and the whole thing goes
wrong and then you never get around to
deriving it yourself but that is
something which every student by the
time they are undergraduates they can do
they don't have to prove themselves to
it on a weekly basis that i can do it i
can do it that's that's done and dusted
but what i think they they can spend a
better like a better investment of their
time would be to actually outsource this
thing to the computer uh which can do
the which is very good at repetitive
tasks and to actually use our brain our
precious brain time to uh to
uh understand clearly the those critical
junctures of the derivation because
that's what really matters
uh instead of being careful with the
plus and minus the
scientific i mean and you can even
generalize it's not just the symbolic
derivation it's also
as the physics and and your background
the same thing you want to solve
ultimately the equations and typically
numerically and so
to actually write programs to
numerically solve those equations even
if it's just a very simple something you
can do yourself you know uh it that's
the best way to learn it
to see to actually get the result the
correct result economist that you are
getting the correct answers then you can
say you truly understood exactly
everything and so the symbolic part is
part of it to actually get the equations
in the first place and then the second
step is to actually implement them
numerically
yeah
plus there is also the thing that once
you have that
a few scripts ready you can keep on
reutilizing them so it's it's like
something like okay i have built it
myself it's my own thing i don't have to
keep proving to myself that i can do it
i can do it again i have done it let me
utilize it
okay
okay so lingering a little bit on your
early days
um so your basic training
uh
was in mathematics and physics
and uh you were i think an undergraduate
student when you first started uh
developing or first started uh writing
up a symbolic python so at that point uh
did you get some kind of mentoring
because i'm sure google summer of code
did not exist back then right
yeah
so you have been a mentor to a lot of
students and we'll come to that but
at that point when you first started
learning or first started writing up
symbolic python did you have any mentors
or was it just
on your own
my own yeah it's so my i mean i
graduated high school i went to study
physics
undergrad so it's just a general physics
so the classes we had is all kinds of
physics and math classes um
as well as experimental physics
like labs i guess it's called in the us
um
which i did not enjoy too much i love
little by the way it's a 10j but i love
the lab the physics labs uh to do the
measurements it's always fun and i did
enjoy kind of interpreting it but i
hated writing it up in the reports it
always took forever
but uh
but anyway i i yeah so i loved i mean if
i did it again i would do exactly the
same thing i would still study physics
um
i think it gives you the foundations to
to everything everything um
but uh yeah regarding programming i
learned that i you know at high school
you know as i mentioned my dad helped me
when i was
then from then on i just kind of learned
on my own as i could
and then at high school i was pretty
good at it
at university i just got to learn
everything on my own so um
yeah and so starting simple so i knew
python i mean i knew c and c plus plus
a little bit of fortran and i knew you
know a lot of python and so i just
started doing it i guess
so a lot of the uh good institutes uh
certainly we have that culture nowadays
uh but back then so this was around 2004
five something like that
uh i think you are just a year older
than i am
physical age
uh so i think it was around that same
time uh so
uh
at your institute i think it was a
charles university in the czech republic
yeah so uh did that institute have some
kind of a programming culture
so they have a computer science
department but i started in the physics
department and so we had i guess one
class the very first semester i think
for programming in pascal i think and
that's it uh that was it well actually i
guess later on we had some numerical uh
programming later but mostly the
i guess
yeah i guess we had some classes but
it's you know it's not enough to you
know it's just a very kind of intro okay
so it's not enough to
you know you have to learn it on your
own i think and
i mean i don't think i guess i didn't i
never felt that i need the the computer
science classes to learn how to
programming i think the best way to
learn programming is to sit down and
start programming it's not
that i think it's not the hard part the
hard part is to know the the equations i
guess for for physics and engineering is
to know the equations at the moment and
that's something that's extremely hard
at least what i found out for myself
learning the programming part is easy
the hard part is to
learn the physics uh and that's that's
something that's extremely hard to learn
on my own because
it's a lot completely overwhelming and
it's tough to kind of even you know
know what to learn and then so on and it
takes real investment and so the the
that's what the university really gave
me is
the physics about background uh the
computer science like the technical you
know programming
uh
tasks it's i don't think i think anybody
can learn it it's not that much to it i
think
uh so you mentioned this on your own i
was about to ask you so uh your
undergraduate
formal training has been in mathematics
and physics so also your master's uh
and
the kind of projects that you did the
actual scientific projects uh that where
those were i think uh in the general
area of chemical physics uh
right yeah so i guess i shouldn't choose
i always wanted kind of computational
numerical uh
yeah so at that point uh you were doing
your actual scientific project work and
at the same time developing
uh symbolic python and things like this
yeah so during my undergrad you have to
do a bachelor thesis i think
so that's a project
well the classes some classes require
projects uh yeah so that's the usual
schoolwork i think it's actually very
kind of the same and then in addition in
the evenings and nights especially um i
was working on simba yes
you must have been a very very
academically serious student
well i mean so so during the batch so i
guess when i entered university i was
you know well ahead in physics and math
and so i kind of took you know very
quickly the advanced classes so the
bachelor i kind of got out of the way
pretty quickly so in the third year
actually
so it's only three years in the czech
republic the bachelor was only three
years so in the third year i had a lot
of time i think so
um so i was kind of focusing on simpai
what got me in trouble is during my
master because then i kind of did not
realize i studied theoretical physics
and so what happens is that the bachelor
as i remember is relatively easy it's
not much uh just kind of basic physics
you know basic quantum mechanics and all
the math and so on but it's not very
difficult the difficult part which i
wasn't prepared for comes during the
master because i studied theoretical
physics and so that's when the
uh the general relativity and quantum
field theory comes in not just intro but
the actual and it requires a lot of
effort to pass and so i almost uh almost
failed um
uh uh university because i was focusing
on simply and i thought yeah this is
kind of you know easy and then didn't
realize oh this requires a real real
effort to learn
so uh yeah so anyway uh yeah i guess my
schedule back then was um i pretty much
did my classes in i think in the
afternoon then i came home and then just
uh in the evening just kind of worked
from i don't know six let's say or eight
p.m till two a.m or sometimes four a.m
or even six a.m depending on the day and
then i slept till noon let's say that i
went back to university for a couple
classes in the afternoons and that's
kind of how i
did it so i remember
so i started senpai and then i just kind
of did initial let's say for a month or
two i kind of initial
work and then i kind of
you know let it sit
and then
a person from spain his name is fabian
pedrego sahia just started contributing
and so
you know so when i saw somebody actually
contributing to the code as well and
that's you know it was
you know a lot more encouraging to work
together and so that so we for maybe a
month or two we worked really hard on
this
and then i signed up for google summer
of code so we had i think five students
the first year and that's how it kind of
got off
it took off and um
and after that
i i worked really hard on it i realized
oh this is a really huge potential and
so i worked really hard on it for half a
year to a year pretty much every day
every night
uh so doing the school and then i came
home and just
you know worked
through the whole night it's kind of
back then it was easy because
uh night is quiet so i can focus on on
it and you know no no interactions no no
disturbance and so i can really focus on
uh you know give it the hours that it
needed
and then once it you know once the
project is advanced enough then it kind
of the ball eventually starts rolling on
its own
but the hard part is to get it there so
that's that's why i did it
uh so does that mean that after your
masters you kind of took a break from
everything else to focus on senpai
development
no well
no i kind of did it during my master
almost almost failed the university but
then i kind of you know
got back on track
graduated
and then i came
to the us to do my phd
and then this was at the university of
nevada
right
nobody know um started phd in chemical
physics and then i could i think the
first year or two i was also working
pretty hard on supply and then
eventually i had to then
at that point it was already doing
really well so it didn't need me as much
and then i had to
then stop working only to focus on the
phd to be able to finish it so then that
you know when you want to start i think
i'm sure you know the thesis that you
really have to [ __ ] yourself
kind of my focus your mind and so i kind
of gave up all that and early focus to
get the phd out of the way and after
that i guess i then got a post doc and
and a job and so
um
i kind of work with senpai
as a mentor and as well as helping
organize and the financials and so on
but the day-to-day activities i wasn't
as involved
so
please don't mind me asking this so
we have heard of these uh stories uh so
the people make movies and uh like they
they hike up these kind of stories uh
where people make something uh from the
software world uh and then they drop out
of university uh
which i personally as as a professor i
do not i do not come i mean i cannot
support that kind of behavior so it's
quite encouraging to hear your story
that uh you were doing this but then you
always kept getting back on track and
finishing what you had actually started
at university
uh yeah i encourage the same thing now
things might be different if i was born
in the u.s because the opportunities
here are you know very tempting and of
course much bigger but uh in the czech
republic the only way to get you know
for me to have the career that i wanted
the only way is to finish your schools
you cannot get you cannot drop off
because then it just kind of
closes the the doors
so uh but yes it's extremely tempting
because
it's you know it's uh if you do
something that's impactful right you
know as a meaning let's say the senpai
in my case then
it's very tempting to or you know
obviously you kind of ask yourself a
question why
why are you you know
studying at all instead of focusing on
this full time but
uh that's my approach was to get these
get the schools out of the way while i'm
still young because
as you get older
there's just no way i would do another
you know
school like that you know because then
it requires a lot of time which i had
when i was young but don't have any more
and so so i knew that so i knew that you
know i cannot like when it when it goes
really close to to being uh
to be able to i mean really close to
dropping out i i realized now i need to
i really need to focus on the school and
not not getting myself kicked out so
this kind of a thought player role may
be a part of the role at least that you
were engaged at least at that time uh in
something like symbolic python
which has its utilities primarily in the
physical sciences arguably
uh and you were i mean formerly a
student of physics
so it would be like kind of betraying
your original
uh
your your mothership
uh if you abandoned
physics
and and probably i think in the longer
run that has stolen good state right so
your your completed training in physics
may be that uh that informed your
uh your work in symbolic python so me
i'm just guessing here okay so correct
me if i'm wrong so probably that
yeah no
yeah no no doubt that's um
the physics
or engineering too uh your background is
very similar from this perspective it's
um
it's
very i would say applied from the
computer science perspective like i was
always interested in in the actual you
know results i guess
as well as i'm interested in
maintainable software as a kind of an
engineering product but
but i'm not i've never was interested in
kind of abstract
math or abstract something that's not
really applicable and so
uh from the simple so there is lot so
when i started zinpa there are a lot of
even back then a lot of other
libraries even open source libraries uh
such as maximum
[Music]
axiom
maxima is open source
yeah okay yeah it was already open
source back then um
but
a lot of times the civic axiom it was
tremendously powerful in terms of uh it
had some really i mean geniuses working
on it so it had integration for example
for integrals one of the best
you know ever even from conversion
software but it always was just kind of
tailored a lot of times to kind of
abstract things it wasn't as easily
applicable to you know basic tasks like
like simply is
um and maxima is very nice actually
maximize i think applicable except that
it's written in lisp and i tried oh man
i'm not against lisp or anything it's
just that it's how to
kind of understand it and modify it i
tried they they had some bugs and limits
and i tried to go in and decode and see
if i can fix it but it's just it was
really hard for me to
to to get into it and so the barrier i
would say to entry to contribute it's
really high and that you were asking why
i chose python i think the barrier to
contribute to python is really low it's
like anybody can learn it quickly and
it's kind of natural intuitive
and lisp is just
not intuitive to me at least you know
right so
so uh
probably we can uh circle back to this
uh thing you mentioned about the the
lower uh
entry barrier to python uh does that
if you could just linger on that a
little bit
do you think
that has something to do with the way
the language itself is designed meaning
that it's somewhat closer to the way
that
we as human beings tend to think
uh
it's
it's not it's a little bit less uh
punitive or perhaps a little bit more
forgiving uh to our lose way of thinking
as human beings we when we
we make certain assumptions that the
other people will will pick up on
certain unsafe things so
now python probably is a little bit
more forgiving on that account and so a
little bit closer to the way we think as
human beings
do you think that's
maybe
yeah i think it's a lot um
for somebody who's not an expert in
programming maybe complete beginner or
just
ver you know just a beginner i think
it's a lot easier you just kind of tell
it's imperative so you just kind of call
some functions and create some arrays
and
you know do some computation and
uh it's interactive so you can
interact interactively see the answer
right away and you can
explore the answers you can kind of
explore the what you are trying to
compute and kind of iteratively
explanatory
do exploratory work and arrive at
something that almost works or
ultimately works and then you put it
into a script
and so i would say this kind of workflow
is very very good mathematica has a
similar workflow matlab also uh and i
think this workflow
and i think it's very kind of
good for beginners
i think lisp is fine a lot of people
like lisp but it's it requires
investment i guess uh
learn and so
if uh your background is physics for
example or engineering um
it
um you know
it
you know i think the barrier is higher
intuitively it seems to me for me at
least it is let's put it that way for me
it was and so that's why i chose python
but i think a lot of people are like
that as well so
so uh after your phd i think you uh did
your postdoc at los alamos
uh yeah and and you stayed there for
quite a few years right until quite
recently
so yeah what was your experience like at
lawson like it's a it's a legendary
place uh in the world
in the public imagination the manhattan
project
the the atom bomb
and the and the entire stories that uh
professor richard feynman had narrated
in his books so it's it's a it's a very
mythical place for people outside it
yes it is
so it's very nice to be able to spend
and work here and i you know i recommend
the place even
it's a big lab it's about 10 um i guess
13 000 people now no they did a lot of
experiments but even in computational
science let's say where i was
at least you know thousands of people
and so so you get and so you'll get to
collaborate with a lot of people just
you know hundreds and um
and very smart people very like i
learned a lot every day i learned
something um and it's you know it's um
from you know i i enjoy computational uh
physical computational science and uh
los alamos is a great place for that
that's what i was doing every day in
some aspects of it um
and also the history and um you know you
can they have archives you can go and
see and it's it's uh
it's you know for me intellectually it's
very satisfying i guess and um
and it's it is a famous place they they
um
it's nice to talk to you know like they
if you talk to some of the older you
know people here they remember some of
let's say you know edward teller you
know and stuff like that so you can
you can talk you know it's kind of those
you know virtually those people are long
dead but but people who view them as you
know colleagues you know they some of
them are
live and so it's nice to be able to
uh to talk with them and meet them and
so on um
and
it's uh you know i uh after i get
getting my phd um
you know the options are either you know
get a job in industry or go to academia
or go to a national lab a national lab
is something between academia and
industry so
it's much more applied as a mission you
don't have to typically apply for
funding but you have to be doing what
the mission is so it's not that you have
a freedom like you know kidding me how
to do anything you want you have to be
doing
uh you know
so something that live needs to get done
but because it's a big lab there are a
lot of projects and so if you and once
you get to know enough people there are
so many interesting projects you can
find and work on so
so from this perspective is you have to
kind of
find
i think is similar at any big
corporation uh once
the cooperation is big enough there's
always some nice very interesting
projects you just have to get to know
the people and
and convince them to to fund you but
otherwise um to get you i guess get you
in the project so that you can work on
it but um
yeah so i i recommend the place so uh is
there some kind of an uh incentive on
the employees there and the scientists
more appropriately there to
obtain some kind of funding like
professors are
expected to in a research set in a in a
research university setting is there
some kind of an incentive or
a requirement for the scientists there
to bring in funding on their own people
who work at los alamos or similarly in
other national apps
i would say yeah it depends what you
want to do so if you want to propose
your own research then you have to
figure out how to find it so there's
multiple ways to get it funded there are
some internal grants as you can apply
for
there are outside grants
us i think the office of science and do
you get those grants you can
i think you bring industry funding too
if you know if you have contact and
convince the industry to fund some
research you can do it too
and then if you don't want to bring your
own funding then then typically you
would work with existing projects
and because it's a big lab a lot of
projects as always so it depends what
you want to do but like to say in my
case i wanted to do computational
uh you know physics
structure as well as kind of the big
about the physics codes and learn some
of the methods and so on but
and also i enjoy kind of
doing basic research as well as applied
and so
as long as and my approach was kind of
open and so i always found a lot of
interesting projects to work on in here
so simba was your baby right and you are
now in a national lab so did you get
some funding on your own
was that kind of encouraged
for for the development of senpai and
your other projects so we will come to a
discussion on fortran and el porter and
the work that they've been more recently
doing but did you get some funding on
that
i was hoping to get better not figure
out how to do that so and so though and
i think um
i uh
so
so
so
kind of interesting thing almost every
group uh the computational groups in los
alamos there's at least one person who
uses senpai so that was very
but
typically they use it maybe once a month
you know to compute some stuff but they
don't use it on everyday basis and so
it's hard to then fund the development
for something that you use once a month
um
and and you know development of simpli
just like any project requires uh you
know it needs to be a full-time you know
uh job and so
one approach that i thought
you know is to kind of get little
funding from multiple projects and kind
of patch it up together but it's hard to
do in practice so i did not succeed uh
to get it funded or to get
funding for surprise
all right
so
uh
regarding the development outside uh
moon uh this structured environment um
so beyond the university beyond this
national labs so there has been a an
ever growing presence from the open
source community uh contributing to
symbolic python as well as other
projects that you've been working on
so uh
through this process you have been a
mentor to many many students
and quite a few of them have been from
india especially for symbolic python it
just so happens that many of them have
been from india i think quite a few of
them from the iits also so uh how did it
actually come about why is there such a
bigger
presence of indian students specifically
in this particular project of sempai
so i don't know i think uh that i don't
know i think uh it probably india has a
lot of students a lot of uh
you know i don't know it's also i think
the money that you get last year for
google summer of gold we used to and i
think it still does gets you know quite
far in india so it's in terms of
i guess
for somebody let's say from you know
europe you know it's not doesn't go as
far so that might be one of the reason
but it's more to it i don't know it
might also be that once
it kind of starts then the younger
students see the older students and it's
just kind of a culture yeah that's
that's one of the big big reasons
because uh i mean if we extend that
argument then we have sufficient
students to contribute equally to numpy
and other open source projects but we
don't see such a big presence
but i think in general for google summer
of course there are a lot of students
from india even in general
right
yeah but within the python ecosystem i
think
it's like a disproportionately high
number of indian students in sempai
right
yes but i think it that might also be
because we've i realized that this is a
very nice way to to get a lot of good
work done and
so recruit students and then they become
mentors next year let's say and and you
know and and just have a lot of
collaborators that way and so
um i i enjoy working with students and
so i you know i always spend
a lot of effort to to make sure that we
have a lot of students every year
and if you don't put the effort in then
you know then
then you don't get students i guess so
so maybe that that's also part of it i
really think so i mean those are the
main two reasons like after a student
has gone to a certain mentor and if the
experience has been good that
information gets passed down over
generations
so
that kind of feeds back over the years
and
it's a snowball effect i think
so do you want to mention something
about the google summer of code so
i think even beyond indian students you
have had some excellent contributors uh
some long-term contributors that you
initially met through the google summer
report i think the current lead
developer of senpai dr aaron moyer i
think uh i don't know how to pronounce
his name
aaron yeah so i think he was through uh
he made him first with the google summer
of code right in
2007 was it
so seven or eight yeah i
stayed there all the time and
when i was focusing on my phd i realized
you know i have to i have to find
somebody to take over and he was the
most natural you know the most active
and
uh
and excited and young and everything so
i figured you know what i'm just gonna
go with it
and he's done a tremendous uh job in
fact when i
when he became and i just said you know
from now on you are
the main person he uh he just simply
flourished he just you know that's i
think when we got to the google summer
of course our own organization the first
time and he he really just took sympathy
to the next level
so
that also tells me a lot of lessons too
is that
like you do something for a couple of
years but
you kind of done the the 80 that's easy
and then the rest 20 percent it can take
the rest of my life to get and i never
get if i kind of pass it over to
somebody else they can then take it take
where i got it and just just bring it
much further than i ever would so
uh so i'm actually very happy that
i've done that so early because it uh i
would not be able to see if i would not
be here if i did not do that because i
would not be able to
um i have strengths and weaknesses and
he and he just you know kind of
compliments beautifully and so
it um
was a great choice yeah so that's aaron
and i guess
i met so many i mean great people
through through just the google server
of code it's
it's a nice um the google summer of code
is nice that it allows you to
just meet people you would otherwise not
meet and um
it
so i have a lot of the early students
i'm still in touch with uh um
materia for example from paul les was
another one he implemented
i think that was from 2007 and he
implemented
all the polynomial support and all the
integration all the difficult
um
polynomial factorization and stuff like
that
um
and then
and you know we just kept in touch over
the years
and just like that with many other
students and so
um yeah so it was very enjoyable
uh so iron i think is a maths phd right
i don't know if you're as a phd but yes
at least as a math student master right
student okay so i think that uh really
very well complemented uh
the kind of input that you had initially
given in sempai so from the physics side
and then from the math side
so the stars are actually lined up for
simply
okay so
now my next question is that uh
we have been talking about sempai quite
a bit uh let's now move on to some of
the very very interesting work that you
have been doing uh
not recently but more recently compared
to sempai uh on resurrecting portrait
now
uh
for for nerds like us i think there's a
movie there
but
we will get by with your story for now
so tell us the story of how you are
resurrecting fortran
well so
so as we discussed you know to be able
to
learn something you have to actually
become in here do it by hand but but
preferably on the computer and so for
the symbolic part you know simplifies it
you know
one of the choices but
um when you want to implement something
numerically um
then you have different kind of choices
so you can use matlab and python as well
in numpy
but has issues with performance and also
the other issue with that is once
if you just want
to do a prototype that i think python on
matlab is ideal but once you want to
have a code that you maintain over the
span of days and weeks and years even if
you are the only developer then i
kind of over the years i used to do it
in python but over the years i kind of
and now much prefer something like
fortran and the reason is that
it's compiled so
it's much more robust long term
with python what happens the main
difference between let's say fortran and
python is that
um
in in python you have to test
you have to have tests for syntax so if
you make a mis so
python itself parses the syntax but if
you for example use a variable that's
not defined or
mis-type something or more typically you
refected the code and you forget that
something doesn't work anymore because
it doesn't align
maybe maybe you add an argument to a
function and so on
um
python doesn't help you at all you have
to have tests and you have to run the
tests to discover that and those can
take a long time especially for
computational stuff to discover that
path code path that fails
in fortran or any other compound
language
the compiler catches 90 of these bugs
right away and fast quickly like the
compilation
well fortran first of all it's very fast
to compile but even c plus plus people
say that they compile uh slow and it's
true
but it's still much faster than running
the python test suit and so
c plus plus compiler gives you the the
errors right away
to python and so the development
experience is just
much more robust
for for these you know long running
bigger projects
and then of course when you collaborate
with multiple people
my experience with python is that you
get a pull request
but you have no idea what things broke
and it's hard to tell yes you have to
run the test suit
but even
then it's kind of tough um
with the compound language you just you
know as long as it compiles you know
that at least you know
every function has the correct number of
arguments you know the tabs match you
know like 90 of these easy you know
bugs are fixed like you know they are
just not there and you can focus on the
functionality to make sure nothing or
broke as well as design
so that's kind of what i can kind of
back down to so first you know you were
asking how i started with python so
what's nice about what i liked about
python initially is that and i still
like it that how easy it is to get into
how easy it is to program it and you
know it's very powerful
but then
for but i and i still like it for those
reasons but for
kind of production you know bigger codes
uh
medical codes i kind of came back to
compound languages and so then
uh what options i have for combat
language as well um it really is not
that many uh for for numerical you know
c plus parts that's the obvious choice
and then the function
possibly rust or go at these languages
but
um wheels
performance and so c plus plus is one
option you can this performance out of
it photon the other one um and what's
nice about first turn over c plus plus
is that
it kind of looks like python
that really is you know
it's maybe a little bit more variable so
you have to write subroutine instead of
f instead of def
as in python but it's not that big of a
deal you get used to it
uh it has arrays as part of the language
and it's
it really does look like the python it's
just the only difference is you have to
declare all the types but as i argued
you want to do it anyway and so
you know with fortran like stuff that
you want to do anyway you you do and
then there's not much else uh there and
so it's not a bad not a bad language now
what is what i don't like about fortran
the reason
for running some kind of a downward
trajectory is that
uh the tooling is just not great
uh the compilers uh you know the
packages in general package ecosystem
and um and in overall just the state of
the language or i would say state of the
ecosystem
but
but if the language is good it's just
the tooling that's not that's great that
can be fixed and so that's uh how i got
into and i realized the main thing that
we need is a it's a compiler that
fixes most of the issues i had with
other compilers as well as makes the
language interactive so that it it kind
of looks so that you can use it like
python interactively from a jupyter
notebook or a terminal
so that kind of fixes the main main
issues i had with fortran or once we
deliver it
it will fix those issues um the rest of
the issues are things like
you know running on
uh gpus for example and and some
platforms uh say to give just one
example that will perfectly illustrate
what i'm talking about let's say you buy
a new mac computer
well it's known for turning and it's not
easy to install actually it's impossible
to install um so
while if you want to use c plus plus
then it's first of all already there
clank is there and if you even if it
wasn't typically these you know the c
plus plus compilers are easier to
install and so that you know that kind
of illustrates exactly what i'm talking
about but those things can be fixed and
so
um yeah so that's how i got into it
so right so uh in that little short
paragraph that you just said you have
unloaded a lot of information so let me
see if i can chop this up a little bit
because uh
a lot of the viewers of this
of this channel they are younger
students
so
let's let's uh linger a little bit on
the historicity of fortran so uh
so
fortran predates the birth years of the
majority of the students who would be
watching this video
uh i think i think it predates mine too
i did was first in the 60s right so it
was it's older than both of us
older than that yeah older than that
yeah probably yeah 94 or 5 or 3
something like that yeah
so uh
and and the motivation from the very
outset of development of fortran was to
apply it in the physical sciences in
mathematics uh
in engineering
so correct me if i'm wrong
the initial motivation was to
fortran stands stand it for formula
translation so to translate formulas
into
the broader scope to translate math
or kind of computational math into code
that and there is performing link and
then it runs on every platform so that
you don't have to write it in assembly
and then you go to a new platform and
you have to
assembly and rewrite everything
the idea is to write it just once and it
runs everywhere but it's still
performing very performing so i think
that was the idea i mean assembly back
then
um or even you know today if if you only
have one platform it's actually not
too bad i mean you know you can yes it's
maybe look harder but you can learn the
instructions and eventually
do a program but the hardest is that you
go to a different platform and you can
throw it it will just not run and so the
key is to be able to you know do a much
higher level language
um
and also
i guess
up until recently i would see the intel
x86 platform is just an absolute like
bring back to default but back then
every computer had a different
instruction assets and so you and so
having a language that compiles to all
these computers is a huge win
that is a big deal back then
right uh plus uh as you mentioned
the full form was formula translated
right i didn't know about that
yeah so so i mean i think that directly
uh tells us that it was meant for uh the
sciences right so which is why it i mean
scientists and engineers took naturally
to it
it was it was always meant from the
beginning but let's say we come back to
modern fortune it's meant for array
oriented scientific computing that's
very shy right represents you know if
that's your goal then fortran is a good
choice if that is not your goal if for
example you want to do some string
processing or web development or write
the operating system you know then i
would say don't order
but if your goal is scientific competing
and kind of numerical not symbolic
numerical computing i would say foreign
choice right and uh
i think it's important to make a
distinction between a numerical
computation and symbolic computation so
we were talking earlier about symbolic
python which has its own strengths but
fortran by design is great for
absolutely great for numerical
computations very robust very stable and
it has a long history of uh
excellent libraries now which have been
contributed
over the many many years uh for proper
implementation of the of the actual
mathematical
algorithms is probably the most famous
uh
the api is still used everywhere
even even the open blast which i think
the most
used open source uh fast implementation
of of the you know matrix operations uh
it still has fortran in it for you know
historical reasons and assembly assembly
for the fast implementations but fortran
for the higher level
um
functions
and uh i think uh correct me if i'm
wrong i think matlab initially was uh i
mean the back end was a lot of it was in
fortran right
i think matlab if i'm not mistaken began
as they do for trump i wanted to make it
interactive right kind of like
but
back then they decided we'll have our
own language kind of inspired by fortran
and powered by underneath
and if i'm not mistaken i think uh
somebody have found the original or
maybe the original source code of matlab
i think is online and now available and
i think it's in fortran and i think on
the fortran discourse forum if you go to
fortran dashlane.org there is a
discourse for i think you can find a
link to it and i think people try to
compile it and play with it
so that's how matlab began i think i
i'll get back to you if i can if you can
share that link
maybe i can share with the with our
viewers that will be interesting uh i
think but now uh mathworks have ported
entirely to c plus right
yeah yeah so java i don't know what they
use
right
uh
okay so now you also mentioned something
about the interactivity of forefront
which was largely missing i mean the
math works guys did something about it
but in a completely different way
[Music]
and and very logged in in a proprietary
way uh but your more recent work has
been developing something called l4
trend so could you please tell us
something about it
yes so
the motivation the initial motivation
was that i always
i want to develop some new algorithm uh
so i typically use python and numpy
because it's very easy to
to exploratory you know do exploratory
work and do plots and and so on
um and so
and i've done it many times and then i
have to copy that python code into
production code so either c plus plus or
for trend so let's say for trend well
and then and so you make mistakes while
you manually translate the code and then
you have to debug it again that's just
oh inefficient way to do that you'll be
better to do everything in one language
and so
uh and so if fortran is the target then
you know making photo interactive so
that i can do this exploratory work
with fortran itself even possibly
calling some of the production codes you
know modules to you know set up a mesh
or something
you know get the matrices exactly as
they are maybe in production and then
just do some
i think i was uh coding some eigen
solver
um you know specific for the problem so
uh that was the initial motivation
realizing oh if we can make photon
interactive then i can just code it in a
fortran and then i have it i don't have
to i can just copy and paste it to the
production code i don't have to
translate so that was the main
motivation to make for turn interactive
but while doing it i realized oh i can
also fix all kinds of other issues that
always bugged me as a user and and i
think they can be fixed
one of them is
let's see the compilation speed so for
trunk compiles generally much much
faster than c plus plus but still once
you have a big code you know
half a million million lines it can take
you know quite a bit to compile but
why cannot decompile faster if you have
a faster compiler that compiles faster
so so i designed for trying to spend a
lot of time designing it to make sure it
can compile faster so the internal
internal node sorry internal data
structures are very fast very fast to
construct very fast to visit
and the other things that bother me is
well i would like the compiler to help
me the things that compiler knows
such as
so so fortran
for historical reasons has all kinds of
kind of
um you know design choices that are all
right but it it you know people make
mistakes so for example when you write
1.0 in in fortran
it always means single precision
floating point
so
oh and
then when you assign it to a variable
that's double precision typically you
want to use double precision
well it will pretty much give you random
digits in beyond that single precision
number so for example if you assign like
5.5
you get 5.5 then four or five zeroes and
then random just you know random numbers
whatever was in the memory that you know
so that's terrible uh you don't want
that and so the way of course what you
know
we you know it's recommended is to
always specify the precision of the of
the constant so write it like 5.5 and
then
underscore and then dp where dp stands
for double precision for example but the
problem is if you forget
and i've seen it all all over
production codes just you know most of
the time it is like that but sometimes
you know people forget
and then and then then you get uh just
you know you don't get you're losing
accuracy just by this well you know the
compiler warn about this and not just
war just disallow it why can't the
compiler say just by default just not
even allowing this and say you have to
use you have to specify the precision
that would eliminate these bugs
completely and this is just an example
but there's dozens and dozens of things
like that
that the compiler can completely
eliminate just by not allowing it
and of course yeah you have to have
compiler options to disable it but you
know the default user experience what i
would like for my compiler is to
be kind of like python just
give me good error messages disallow
things that i don't want in the first
place and and just and just make the
language completely safe
and that's completely doable so without
fortran that's that's kind of
our approach or another example um
[Music]
historically fortran because it evolved
over you know 50 60 years it
did not have um
sometimes it has multiple ways of doing
things so for example when you do a less
than
operator so in modern fortran as well as
in python you just do the less you know
angle bracket
but in f77 or
at least you had to use dot
lt dot
and both are supported so with alpha
triangle we already implemented it we
just give a hint we say style hint and
we say use you know in modern fortran
use the angle bracket and so
by giving hints when you compile your
codes i think we can completely pretty
much modernize because nobody wants to
get warnings and so if these are by
default then you know users will realize
oh yeah i should just use it it looks
much better anyway
and that way they can kind of modernize
their codes kind of you know painless
you know it's a kind of painless you can
ignore the warnings it will still run
but you know you don't want to get
warnings and so that way we can
kind of modernize you know modernize and
the language in a way modernize the code
base i would say to just follow kind of
a you know canonical modern approach and
so as a user i want that i want to be i
want that to be informed by the compiler
because that's the only way to really
make this work especially once you have
multiple people working on the project
you know it's hard to uh first of all
sometimes it's
you know everybody's busy you know our
job is to you know get get you know
implement something get it done
but if part of the requirement is to
make sure the code still compiles
without warnings which that's kind of
most you know most people agree on that
well then we can use that to to kind of
enforce some nice you know conventions
so that's another thing another thing
that i would like the compilers to be
doing is
uh to actually
generate fast code in all so in all
cases so historically fortran compilers
were one of the best in terms of uh
generating performing code
but
last
you know maybe 20 30 years they kind of
they started very high but they not
really
improved that much compared to the
competition and so
c plus plus and c compilers now pretty
much caught up um in terms of
performance but
there is still a lot of performance left
on the table typically once you so in
fortran you can open it on the race
as any operations or or you know all
kinds of multi
you know nested loops and so on
and
uh
it should not be difficult to optimize
some of these things much better than
the compilers currently do to give which
is one example let's take a matrix by a
matrix vector multiply so if you write
it just using two loops and just
multiply it by hand
like that
uh the for triangle baller will you know
generate decent code
so so with c plus plus compiler if you
do that
and and the chord would run roughly at
the same speed except that neither of
them would get you the peak performance
and historically matrix vector multiply
was very difficult to to get the peak
performance how you have to do it in
assembly it just gets very complicated
but lately um all all modern cpus have
fused multiply add
assembly instruction and and they
are very good at uh kind of hiding
latency and so it turns out you can get
the big performance if you unroll the
loop correctly and know which loop which
of those two loops to unroll exactly and
how to do that
it turns out julia has a nice library
called
loop vectorization which that's exactly
what i just described you write a loop
in julia and then you call this library
and then it optimizes the loop to get
you pretty much the big performance much
better than c plus plus of return
compilers would give you by default
so as the user what i would like is that
the compiler to use exactly the same
thing that the loop vectorization is
doing
and
you know so they so this is just one
example but you can you know there's a
lot of examples where the performance is
left in the table and the compiler just
like the template it's almost the same
thing so with simply i thought well why
can't the library do the integrals that
we know how to do
i know that we cannot do every integral
you know and it's impo and it's very
hard to have a general algorithm to do
every integral and systematically but i
know for sure that we can encode many
special cases to just get down the
integrals that we care about in exactly
the same way as the user i know these
loops and so matrix vector matrix matrix
those are very common loops in the
computational codes and maybe it's not
exactly matrix vector maybe it's it's
kind of the same structure but maybe you
do something else with the arrays those
are
there's not that many options and so
having those at least optimized to get
the big performance that's what i want
as a user and it seems to me it's very
easy to do the compiler has the symbolic
you can think of the compiler as simple
it just gives you the code in a symbolic
form
all you have to do is transform it
like supply just transform the symbolic
you know representation of the call to a
different representation and then the
kinds of optimizations to get good
performance you have to unroll the loop
you might need to rearrange a few things
you have to know which loop to unroll
but
by analyzing these loops you know we can
have this optimization passes and so on
um and then we have to you know um work
well with llvm uh that we use to to
generate code but
that all can be done it's nothing i
don't see anything intrinsically why
this cannot be done it just has to be
done and so
um
yeah so as a user those are all the
things that i realized oh i we should
fix them and that you know we this is
what i would like and i think
people once they once once we deliver
and once people you know play with that
and i think they will
they would like to have the same things
as we are trying to implement so
yeah that example you mentioned
regarding the matrix vector modification
so it's something like you have a three
by three matrix and then you multiply it
with a three into one matrix right yes
so that's something which we require on
it like i cannot live half a day without
that thing so we have yeah we have
something called the cautious theorem uh
from elasticity so it's the traction
vector is equal to the stress tensor
times the unit outward normal and
the combinational representation of it
is through a matrix and effect vector
multiplication and each and every
problem that i do i have to do that over
and over and over and over again i mean
that's the entire representation of the
boundary conditions
the only thing is if it's three by three
it's uh then it's kind of tough because
it's too small
oh but it's uh then you know some other
ways
you know um
perhaps completely unrolling it might be
faster but if you do more like 120
hundred by hundreds you know 128 okay
and those kind of matrices you at least
for computational stuff you also need
all the time uh most most computational
codes have some kind of matrices like
that
all electronic structure codes have that
old
most kind of solvers typically have some
kind of a matrix that they need to
operate on and so on so be able to and
it's just a simple example but yeah it's
one of them
of course
for matrix vector for larger kinds of
matrices you have those stiffness
matrices maybe
and find element codes so those kinds of
things definitely you would need some
things like that of course uh if it's
just a matrix vector you can just you
know uh call a library like or open
that's the optimal implementation but uh
oftentimes you don't do it you it's kind
of an example of of of the kind of loop
that you want to write by hand
but but it's not exactly magic vector
maybe you want to do something else in
the body of the loop
but typically you do you typically have
some kind of arrays in the function and
you do some operation on them in the
loops and you will use an area it's a
very common operation in almost all
computational codes
and so be able to optimize at least some
of them some of those loops you know uh
would go a long way
um like actually like optimized to get
the peak performance from the cpu um and
the current compilers neither c plus
plus nor fortran
are able to do that uh so
that's kind of very disappointing in a
way it's still very fast you know don't
get me wrong but if you can get you know
twice or four times better performance
by rearranging the loop well that's a
big deal i think and so as a user that's
what i want and so um
yeah i can tell you like why i think
that is such now when i
am in the compiler business i think
what happens is that um
i think a compiler is just it's a huge
task and so what most you know new
compilers do they write the parser
then they have that's a lot of work it
turns out just you know only getting the
language to parse is a lot of work and
then
they parse it to abstract syntax three
typically it's called ast abstraction
text three
and then they do all the semantics you
know forgetting all the types and so on
and then the random library it just just
it's it's very kind of a low level
work it's a work you have to do as a
compiler because in order to compile the
code you have to all these tasks but
it's very intellectually not very
stimulating it's just something you have
to do
and then by the time you're done you're
so exhausted that you just kind of are
happy to just lower just generate code
you know so at least it runs and so
that's kind of how like most compilers
start and then lately well let's say the
gcc
started a long time ago i assume that's
how they started and then they added
optimization passes and so they have
some kind of intermediate representation
that does all the optimizations
but typically at least historically that
representation is typically low level um
in in let's say modern times we have gcc
and we have llvm those are the two i
would say main kind of two tools and
both of them in a way conceptually it's
not that much different they each have
their own low-level representation it's
kind of like high-level assembly you can
think of it that way so so you still
want to do that and optimize on that
representation but the the kind of
optimizations that you can do are things
like function and lining
for example loops are completely
unrolled you know at that time
i mean completely flattened you know
it's just a jump
what llvm does as well as gcc they
reconstruct the loops
uh so so so the front end takes a
beautiful loop and and converts it to a
jump just jumps and break you know like
um if and kind of conditional jumps
and then llvm takes it and tries to
reconstruct the loop so that's you know
that already tells you something is not
you know not right
live vm is amazing it it
as well as gcc they are able to
reconstruct lot of loops
but uh and and then and then once they
reconstruct it and they can administer
some optimizations on that
but
it already kind of you know probably
tells you you cannot do every
optimization like that and especially
once your code is complicated multiple
nested loops and as well as high level
for track constructs for example you do
some array operations or you call some
runtime library functions um inside the
loops very common you know science
cosigns and you know these kind of
things
or using you know defined functions too
by the time it gets to a llvm oftentimes
it might see
or sometimes you do maybe some
allocation on an array or stuff like
that
by the time it gets to llvm it sees kind
of a calls to a runtime library and so
it doesn't even know how to optimize it
it's hard to do that
and also even if it sees all the code by
the time it gets lower to this low level
representation it's too late to do some
of these optimizations that we would
like to do
so so the whole design if your compiler
only kind of
passes the language and does semantics
but then lowers to whether llvm or gcc
their own representation
you can only do that much and so when it
comes to these loops you really want to
see the original language and really see
as to look as as written and and
optimize those before you lower
and i think historically just you know
it's hard to redesign a compiler once
it's written it's extremely hard because
it's such a big project and so i think
you know for one reason or the other i
think most compilers just kind of do the
semantics and then just kind of lower
and so with the fortran what we do is we
do that we parse to ast but instead of
doing just the semantics and lowering we
actually kind of we have a
representation called abstract semantic
representation asr which does not it's
not lowered so it represents every
fortran feature faithfully as as so so
in other words it has for loops it has
all the types it has every every
semantic you know construct of the
language is represented 101 faithfully
so you can for example take that and
transform it back to full term if you
want it and you will not lose any
you get a functional equivalent code
high-level code
and so what that allows us to do is to
do optimizations at this high level
and so for example uh we started adding
um
things like
let's say you call a modulo function and
you you want to flip a sign of um
just to give an example
when you want to implement the sign
function you want to do argument
reduction and so
you typically have a construct there if
the
module of the argument is if it's odd or
even then you want to flip a sign of the
argument let's say for a side depending
on the quadrant which you are in it's a
very common operation well it's hard to
optimize if um
um you know you want to start once you
lower it and you know maybe it's a
random function call for the modulo and
so on it might be hard at the asl level
it's super simple to write the optimizer
so we've done we literally kind of
better match that operation
and we see it we we transform it to our
own runtime function and then in the
back end we implement efficient assembly
instructions you can use some bit bit
tricks on the on how the floating point
number is represented to get a very fast
implementation it's just an example
it's very natural to do their way so
with the loops we are planning to do
exactly the same thing
when we have the loop structure we would
like to optimize it at this high level
before we lower to llvm and that's how i
think we can get the you know the
performance the big performance
so andre uh you have talked quite a bit
about
the back end of things so
as an as an end user uh so
i was pretty uh excited to learn about
the interactivity uh that you mentioned
with l fortran so how how does it
actually look like uh so as an end user
what do i actually look at because i
haven't tried out l4 sorry so can you
just tell tell us
like it looks like someone typed in
matlab or python if i if i just write 2
plus 2 it gives me four
right and if i write x plus y whole
squared in sim pi it gives me x squared
plus y squared plus a and dot expand uh
it'll give me that expansion so how does
it work in portrait in a compiled
language
same thing so you you so to launch
python in the terminal you type python
and you get a prompt in the four plus
phone
yeah so
with alphatron you you type l4 in a
terminal you get a prompt you type four
plus four and you get it eight so it
looks exactly the same
and then uh for uh variables so it's
still for trends you have to declare
variables so if you type type x equals
five it tells you that x is not defined
but you define it you type integer
x that defines x as integer then you do
x five and now you have the variable and
you can do x plus five whatever
just like python
we can i mean we can even make it even
closer by not requiring to declare
variables but it's one of the things
that i'm not sure if it's a good design
and so we'll almost definitely have it
as a as an option
using a compiler flag
but i don't want to make it the default
at least not now because if we make it
the default we can never take it back
because people start using it and then
it will break their code so i want to be
careful with that but technically it's
even possible to insert the variable
types automatically from the right-hand
side so it can look almost like python
okay now you are getting me excited
about this so uh
so
you remember how in matlab once we run a
script that in the workspace the
variables get stored right
and i think it's a similar sort of thing
in interactive python also
again if you if you re if you create a
script the variables get what now they
get stored in the workspace of matlab
and then from the command line you can
access those variables and play around
with that i used to love that that
aspect of matlab during my phd work uh
so i i mentioned yeah to you over email
right my entire phd work was in matlab
uh so uh so is there is that something
possible in using l4 trend also so you
have a separate script like a proper
program full full length program uh a
dot f90 program in in fortran you run
that and those all those variable values
the the output values they get stored in
a some kind of a workspace and then you
you access that from the l4 trend prompt
something like that
yeah so i guess we haven't implemented
yet to load a script from a file but
we should do that nobody i mentioned it
it's a good example and essentially i
think python or ipython works the same
way if your python works the same way
yeah you just have to be a little bit
careful with the directory which of
course you have to be in matlab also
so if python if i remember well when you
load the script it kind of loads it in
your current scope so all the variables
in that screen will suddenly become part
of your current scope and you can have
it yeah exactly
so alfred works exactly the same way we
just don't have it yet implemented the
load to load the script but if you copy
and paste the script by hand you know as
in
[Music]
it will behave just like you described
so every variable now becomes available
in that prompt so you can use it and it
has the value
that it has so you can do some positive
computation
and store the result in the variable
and then you have it you can use it
interactively wonderful that's what i
have to try this now
because i think the way that i use
matlab i think it was just as a more
forgiving uh
front-end for fortran i i barely even
used any of those built-in
uh fabulous functionalities of matlab
except maybe od45
uh
yes that's what i realized too i think
we you you know i think it will be
exactly what people want once they once
once they see it the only thing i have
to worry
aboutron is in alpha stage so what it
means is that it works it works
interactively composed two binaries but
you have to but it has limitations and
so you need to be
willing to uh work around the
limitations so you'll discover things
that are not implemented yet so
typically you get some kind of an
exception saying it's not implemented
yet so that's not going to work also in
the interactive prompt
so the compilation of into binaries is
pretty advanced we can compile quite a
lot of fortran
you know we have modules and subroutines
functions and you know almost every
fortran feature is implemented to some
extent
but
some of the advanced features like
classes they are implemented in the most
basic form but you try to do anything
more advanced it will not work yet
um
but but we have arrays we have all those
integer complex you know real types uh
we can functions we have seen their
operation you know we have quite a lot
of things but uh not everything is
implemented fully and so you almost
always discover something that doesn't
work but typically it's possible to work
around now the interactive prompt has
even more limitations you know so you'll
discover bugs it's an alpha stage but
our goal is to bring it now to a beta
stage which is which my definition is
that it needs to pretty much just work
it will have bugs but but for the most
part i think pretty much everything
should work so we are not in beta stage
we are still an offer so it's kind of a
caveat if you try for uh trifold fortran
uh report all the bugs you discover well
that's fine that's fine absolutely fine
all right so um
now this this one uh
one contentious point which i had
mentioned uh earlier so uh
as you can see so i'm closer to your age
and i got immediately excited by
focusing even though i have never
actually used fortran for any of my
projects i did touch upon it a little
bit but i never really got around to
actually using it but still i got
excited by this prospect of
i mean uh
like if there is a real full-fledged uh
functionality of involving the
interactivity in fortran i think i would
ditch everything else and just move over
there
i think you are not the only one
so i think uh i just got to mention i i
think once we get to beta yeah i think
with boom of like once people try it out
realize oh this is this is superior um
there'll be a lot of lot of users of
this yeah yeah i mentioned at the
library i used to work
it every group had maybe one person who
used team pi maybe once a month
once we deliver on hell for trying to
compile the production codes uh there'll
be people in every group who you would
use it every day and so that's a whole
different game different
but but here's the contentious point i
wanted to raise that
these old-timers like us
arguably speaking so we would definitely
get excited right and
i think uh
you would also get a lot of excited
people among the absolutely young
generation so people who would like to
actively develop to something uh
something so very new and at the same
time old
however
for production purposes let's say we
have a senior graduate student
or some kind of an early career
research person
uh
how
do you think
they would uh take to it would they
start gravitating towards fortran what
is your take like it's just a i mean
there's no correct answer here right so
how do you think would they would they
gravitate towards it
uh would they shy away from it what do
you think will happen
it depends um i think
in general maybe if i can generalize
your question the question could be
reformulated as what is the future for
channel what is like you know what's the
like does it make sense to invest in
learning for training using fortran
and and i don't know so
the way i see it around me is that
for um
so fortune historically had a lot of
production codes
still has
but in terms of uh
where things are moving uh in what i see
at least personally
so the reason i'm saying personally
because other people disagree but what i
see myself in my own eyes uh and my
experience is that people the these
projects are moving away from fortran to
c plus plus
you know increasing rate
uh and the reason is that um
you know the new supercomputer comes in
has gpus on every node you need to be
able to run it maybe not ideally but at
least you need to be able to run the
code on those gpus otherwise uh it's
hard to justify
well
partly political but partly practical
reasons you need you know you need to be
able to run on it and it's
sometimes completely impossible a bit
for trunk sometimes it's possible if you
rewrite the code a lot
and
with g plus plus at least you have
libraries like cocos as an example array
libraries that just run on gpus
maybe not ideally maybe you know there's
all kinds of limitations uh the c plus
plus uh code in my opinion is much
more variable or less readable if you
compare coco's code you know how you
actually have to write zebra sports code
and the array code converter for turn is
much more
you know slower to compile
worse error messages
possibly worse performance on a cpu
um you know almost everything is worse
but it runs and so that's the number one
you need to be able to run on modern
platforms and so
and and it's like if there was a path
forward i think people would be willing
to to you know work around just like
they are willing to work around the c
spot limitations
but c plus plus at least as a path
forward fortran
and you know
in many respects does not have a path
forward or in the minds of the people
who have to run these projects and so
that's kind of the main reason as i see
it now i think this can be fixed i think
one of the reasons i
i want to also fix it i want i don't see
why
the the fortune language could not run
on the gpu
naturally and provide the infrastructure
and so on
in water but but uh
but i think that's the main reason yeah
so to answer your question
um
i would say um for the big production
codes a lot of times a lot of the new
efforts are in c plus plus as i can see
um for the reasons i mentioned um so
yeah so then the future is not so bright
but the way i see it is that it's kind
of like a huge ship and so in a way
the there is there are these big codes
that use that are in fortran
and then
there is nothing in between and then
there are some very small codes kind of
from you know people are starting and
there's nothing in between and then the
the tooling is kind of
you know and as well as kind of actually
running on on this platform is just not
not really existent or not very good
nothing not in a good shape and so
um
so the in my mind what i see is that i'm
focusing on these small projects kind of
from scratch like like like you
mentioned you would be excited to try
using it
there'll be a lot of people like that i
have no doubt um so i think it will
that's kind of what i call the
resurrection
you know i published a blog post called
resurrecting fortran and a lot of people
objected they say no fortran was not
that you know this is
but it was acting but
um but in my mind you know i i i i
thought about it a lot and maybe you
know
i mean i had a lot of arguments with
them but i i still think you know the
way in my mind it's just not doing great
but i think we can we can fix it and so
uh start for for small projects when i
talk to let's say postdocs who come you
know into like i asked them what what
tools do you use to program they said
well matlab python
and then i asked them what do you
do to run production and this yeah then
i rewrite to c plus or fortran and i ask
them well what if you could do
everything in fortran interactively and
then you have it well
i would use it right away so you see um
i think that's what will happen is that
people you know start kind of using it
for small projects and kind of we kind
of build up the community we and we
actually are making excellent progress
and kind of building up the community
around fortran
and in my mind i'm focusing kind of on
small projects you know and kind of
kind of
laying the foundations the
infrastructure in the foundations and
you know
since we only started
two years ago let's say uh you cannot
expect
you know to have you know to be ready
for production for big codes in two
years it's just you know
so if your goal is to work on these big
production codes then i would then you
know it depends but um you know if i was
a manager of a big production code maybe
i would move
to see plus plus also because you need
to be able to run
you know in the near time frame on these
on these machines and so
and also the tooling you know you don't
have to fight the tooling and so on
but
um but anyway so that would be the
answer so if you know
to you as you were saying as you were
asking about uh somebody who's finishing
the phd let's say it depends on what
kind of code they are thinking of
contributing if it's their own code i
did you know my phd for trend and i
would do it again but if it's a some
kind of a bigger production code you
know then well then ultimately it's not
even their choice typically you have to
use that language that the code is
written in and that's increasingly i
would say c plus plus
but i think um once we fix the
infrastructure for trend so that um we
can
for small projects and we kind of build
up the community you know i think things
can change so in the you know if you ask
me in five years things can be uh very
i'm hoping very much better
um so one encouraging thing that i have
actually noticed so this is my own
experience as a layman user
uh
is that
back in during my own phd days when i
was using matlab day in and day out
uh in one of those days one of those
weeks when i had more time and not much
money and you you just pack around on
the internet
i was
maybe
tinkering with the idea that maybe i
could start using fortran because you
know as young graduate students you
always gravitate to the entire
philosophy of open source and the
traction of it uh
it was really hard to get any
information on fortran
it was really really hard i couldn't
make head or tail out of it like should
i use should i start writing a program
using dot f77 or not f90 what what am i
supposed to do as a beginner so i was
scratching my head literally
but now i actually after i decided that
i would have this discussion session
with you i looked up the the things that
you guys have set up it's it's
beautifully structured beautifully
organized i wish i i wish i was younger
now i really wish i was younger
thank you
but i'm happy you are saying that that
means people who are younger i'm hoping
they will contribute uh they are
i think that's how how things will get
resurrected and i think i was in the
same position about 10 years ago i
wanted to kind of see what's the
what is the
state like how am i supposed to program
in fortran and just like you out there
was nothing so i actually created the
page
fortran90.org back then 10 years ago and
i just kind of
painfully figured out what's the
what's what's
which way you are supposed to use for
trend and documented it by the way i'll
put all the links in the description of
this video
all on the great websites that you guys
have created
10 years ago but i was hoping to kind of
create a community around it but fail is
very hard you know as anybody who tries
very hard to create an open source
community but we succeeded before tron
lang and we are in the process we all
reported the tutorial and we are in the
process of porting the fruit 190 page
completely to for translating so this is
just one resource one page one for
drawing page
the fortran language it's
one in the lifetime opportunity we
managed to pull off something that i
would not think is possible
if you searched fortran in google let's
say uh two years ago
there's nothing there is
you just get random pages there is um
just
you just get kind of random pages no
there is no central page
yeah
well no
authoritative source of
i know no centralized community the
community in a way
that i would say this turns out there's
a lot of people who still use fortran
but they are not organized and then
and and also no logo nothing well and we
managed within a year i think we managed
to get
to create a page and when you search for
trend it's now the second or first page
in google and every other search engine
the the competing page is wikipedia for
for fortran
some search engines put our page for a
sub page you could put a second but
either way if you just search for now
our page the photo online.org comes
first and
we it's open to the page itself is open
source i'm encouraging anybody to
contribute um we may we
run it as a community maintain uh
resource uh we have a discussion forum
you know uh anything you would like to
change or improve let us know how you
can you know and we also are looking
always for more contributors but the
fact that we managed to create the page
for fortran that you now search for tron
and the page comes up it's amazing i
thought it's not possible and then the
other thing we actually created the logo
for fortran also i thought not possible
we created the logo and then
[Music]
somebody put it on wikipedia not us
and uh elsewhere and now it's i see
people when they when they let's say
compare languages they use the fortran
logo that we created as a local fortran
so again it's just something i thought
it's not possible and so i think that
kind of you know uh brings me the hope
that i think we will
uh succeed ultimately um and so we
bootstrapped this community and that's
doing really well um and i you know
encouraging anybody wants to learn
anything about fortran to join and ask
questions and so on
my own focus is mainly on the compiler
because that's something where
it still needs to happen you know you
can have all the community you want but
you need a good compiler um community
kind of controlled maintain compiler
that can we can implement what what's
needed and so that's kind of that's you
know long story short yes i i spent a
lot of time bootstrapping and with i
will join with many others you know
milan and lawrence and sebastian and
many other people um
the pool and peter closler and others um
we really managed to distract it and so
i kind of
i'm not i don't want to say stepping
back but i'm focusing uh 100 on the
compiler because this last part it
absolutely has to be delivered once we
do uh i think uh
things will start looking bright
yeah all the best for that uh okay so
uh
so for someone so so let's take a step
back now um
so you have uh spent
formally the bulk of your carrier being
a computational scientist right
so these are like labels of love senpai
for trend
but your formal their day job has always
been as a computational scientist
so for similar kind of people and for
and for the younger students when i say
a computational scientist i don't mean a
computer scientist right so some people
so so people who use computational uh
work for stuff in physical sciences like
physics chemistry biology mathematics
applied mathematics especially so that
kind of stuff that's what i mean by
computational sciences so for somebody
who is
uh starting out his or her career as a
computational scientist uh now in 2022
what would be your advice for the choice
of a programming language should it
should this so i have been
guilty of uh peddling expertise when i
have actually none and advising younger
students to stick to a particular
language to learn that the syntax of
that language and to spend more time
thinking about the the hurt and soul of
uh of programming itself not tied into a
particular language so this has been my
advice generally that maybe just stick
to python but learn the spirit of
programming first and then
as you grow up you can pick up other
languages as you go along you find it
difficult
uh but i think an advice from you would
be better because
i'm not really qualified for that kind
of advice well my advice is exactly the
same letter python stick to python you
know
you have to know python because it's
when i started python it wasn't the most
popular now it is the most popular
language right i mean
many many
depends are you measuring but you know
one of the most popular let's put in
that way
i would say for uh computational science
i think uh
um you know um scientific computing may
be different term uh python is the kink
it's that you have to know it so i would
start with that then if you have cycles
for more uh learn some compiled language
um you know c plus plus uh is good to
know and fortran is good to know too i
think
um those are i mean even if you don't
will not use fortran it's good to know
at least um it's it's been the first
high-level language it's good to know if
anything then for historical reasons but
i think once we resurrected i think you
will like to learn it i'm hoping you
would like to learn it but uh and also
learn c plus plus because um it's for
it's just a very good tool and so i
recommend that but yeah but definitely
start with python and stick to python
you know get you know uh just do
everything in python you know learn
the libraries get get things done in
python um and then as you need speed um
you can either try some of the python
you know compilers
um
but or just write it in c plus plus or
falter
so uh is it perhaps possible for the
uh for the growing fortran community
that i mean you're one of the prime
drivers behind it to maybe uh
get in touch with the academic
departments and the universities to
i wouldn't say push it but something
along that line uh so if we have young
takers because
a person learning a compiled language
or maybe even students who are familiar
with matlab i don't think they would
find taking too fortran too much
difficult
and maybe over the next five ten years
that can pay dividends
and not just in dividends in getting
more political supporters for the
fortran movement but actually people who
can contribute
fruitfully to
the progress of computational science
using these tools
yeah well um i think
one thing about
fortran is that
the next question that will come as well
can it run how do you run it on the gpus
and then the answer and then once you
start hearing the the current answers
you you know you'll in my opinion you
lose you people will
well that's that's ridiculous i mean i'm
not gonna be
using one commercial compiler to run on
the gpu and another commercial to use on
amd and and then rewriting code or this
or or just writing it in c plus plus and
calling from fortran you know just so
that i can run on the gpu that's just a
little too sorry to start just to me
unacceptable answers and so i think uh
fortran has to have
an acceptable answer first before trying
to i think uh kind of going to academic
departments and pushing it there i think
um
[Music]
so for example let's say what i would
like as a user and an answer that i
would take that is a very solid answer
is that you write your code in the
fortran and then maybe you maybe you
need to annotate
some of the arrays that they are on the
device let's say and then you compile it
through a compiler and it is going to
run on amd gpu and it is going to run on
the nvidia gpu and and you will not be
getting pretty much any and or it will
run on the windows and and
interpret with msvc you know the visual
studio cbs plus compiler on windows
which by the way g4 tran is the mode so
i'll get to the current state but the
vision is it needs to run on a mac you
know on linux or any hpc cluster and so
on
and until we get there um i think it's
kind of probably you know
i don't i don't want to be pushing it
too much i rather want people to
discover us and like you did and realize
oh this is exciting i want to try it out
that's the audience i'm targeting
personally right now i don't want to go
to a cs department and say or
engineering department and saying why
don't you teach fortran because
because i don't have the answer i don't
have an answer that i like to these
questions and so
we will have the answer once we run
you know i think i think universities
will and professors would love it i mean
why not it's a cool it will be cool but
right now so the current state is the
best open source compiler is g4 tran
it's a great compiler it's you know a
lot of people and a lot of people who
contributed to it
they've done you know it's a lot of work
and it's amazing that they managed to
really it it can compile any fortran it
works and so on but
for example on windows it cannot because
it's part of the gcc it cannot link with
msvc so if you are a lot of people who
are using windows and they are using
msvc and they need to be able to
interoperate they need to be able to
link c plus plus code
compile with msvc with uh fortran code
and the g4tran or gcc in general it's
very hard because it uses a different
object file and so on it's a technical
problem but it needs to be solved um
[Music]
and then of course
it you know the g4 train is a great
compiler but it doesn't out of the box
doesn't run on on gpus um it has all you
know you can use open ace openmp i think
offloading but it's not
it's just not not there yet i you know i
would not i would hesitate to kind of
you know bring it to a
engineering department as a production
ready tool uh to run the gpus and
recommending them to use it as as kind
of production and users you see what i
mean because then if it breaks uh and it
will and it will not and you'll they'll
get all kinds of issues um
that's just not a good view if you see
what i mean so um
but um in terms of um you know cs
departments i think
i when i started i'll tell you a story
to kind of give you an idea that it's
absolutely possible and i think they
will love it i when i started alphotron
i didn't know anything about compilers
so i
designed it the best i could you know
what i read and i added compiler books
you know the most famous book is the
dragon book
it's a very thick book but you quickly
realize when you're reading it's not
very applicable to what i want to do
because they spend half of it on parsing
but parsing you have to parse obviously
but you know
so i ended up using bison and re2c for
the tokenizer because it's very fast
speed of compilation is important but
you get it done and then the other half
of the book is spent on the back end how
to implement the back end but in modern
times you can use a little vm if you
care about performance and so on it's
great
but what i care about is the actual
design of the compiler and so there's
only about 50 pages of the whole thick
book
kind of in you know with that aspect and
i was not very impressed by that part
and
because yeah it's um it's tough so i
designed it certain way and then i
went to the czech republic i think i was
visiting and then i had some contacts at
the university in the cs department and
so
so i go there and so i sit up with a
professor i set up a meeting and i was
like oh you know it's gonna be
embarrassing like he'll kick me out of
there like a crank so i go there and i
the design of the compiler showed him
what he you know
and he's like no
that's not it's not too bad that's what
he said congratulations
so he he
agreed approved and and and then and the
last question he says why fortran
and so i explained you know the
motivation
you know
and
so he did not kick me out of there and
then the next year i was much more
advanced and i came there again and we
spent i should maybe one or two hours
actually discussing all the details and
he was very interested you know and i
think the cs departments
for sure would be interested in this
because they like compilers and it's you
know we'll see
lack of powers a lot and so there's a
lot of that in in fortran email fortran
let's say
and then for engineering and other
departments it just needs to be
it just needs to be usable like python
is you download python and you download
these libraries and use conda or spec or
whatever way you want to install it pip
and it will work mostly
so
or it can be made to work so if it
doesn't work typically it's possible to
make it to work but
and it will run and you can use and you
have libraries to run on gpus and so on
and it will just work
and so we need to get to the same stage
with bit for trend um
so yeah
yeah i think i think usability is great
so uh so just going back for just a
second on the same pie thing uh
currently
in senpai you cannot
state that there are two positive
variables like a and b and you cannot
say that a is less than b
and then uh expect
all the computations to properly replace
all the although all the places where a
has to be less than b and then get
replaced so we have to do that manually
uh so this is particularly
important for
uh for problems involving beam bending
where the load is placed at a certain
point
and and you know for a fact that that
distance is less than the length of the
beam but still i mean simply it's a hard
to make simple i understand
automatically so i mean at the very last
we do the entire entire
work and then in the last step we just
do a manual replace and it works
perfectly there's no problem
uh
and i told the students to do this and
they have taken it so
no grudges no no reluctance nothing
if it's usable it works with with one
extra line of i mean
it's a little annoyance we can get over
it
yeah and so
as long as you are willing to work
around the current limitations fortran
is perfectly fine for production as
great compilers you know and then if it
cannot run well on gpu then you just
don't run on energy as as long as you
can take that as an answer yeah if it
doesn't you know then don't use gpus
like you know it's much easier to not
use them in terms of programming anyway
so
uh if that's then i would say proton is
perfectly ready has been for 60 years
but but as i said you must be willing to
work around these limitations and so
for some applications it's not what
you have to run on the gpu as an example
so then you are really in big big
trouble but as long as it's um it's a
like
you know students myself included 10
years ago
it works beautifully and you get
beautiful performance
very readable code
it's easy to program in you get good
error messages quick compile times you
get a beautiful binary you optimize it
so first of all in debug mode you enable
bounce checking so i don't know you know
your viewers might not know fortran code
in debug mode if you enable all the
debug mode flags in g4 tran cannot set
fault
there can be some bugs in a compiler but
assuming there are no bugs in the
compiler the code pretty much cannot
take fault and it cannot leak memory as
long as you use allocatable arrays so
keep that in mind that's amazing um
and then you enable in the release mode
you enable all the optimizations it can
check for the release mode because you
don't do bounce checking you don't want
to do bank checking but the idea is that
you debug your code in debug mode and
run the test suite and run your even
production kind of input file at least a
few iterations to kind of see that
everything works and then you recompile
in the release mode and you get
beautiful performance very very hard to
match from c plus plus it always is
possible to match but a bit more work
even myself when i do some kind of
computational task
it's easy to do in fortran i get decent
performance and then i rewrite to c plus
plus and i get slower performance and
then i spend hours trying to figure out
why
i can always match it but it takes more
more work and so
you know if that's your if so and so um
i think fortran is awesome from this
perspective and completely ready for
production
but
you know as i said it has these caveats
and um if you if you're willing to work
around them then it's perfect
uh so andre uh uh sorry i'm overshooting
the time is it okay if we just
keep the discussion going i really want
to ask you a few more questions all
right
i i have all the time in the world it's
and nobody's going to disturb me now at
11 30 at night
uh okay so
um
so the role of research software
ingenious so
uh this is something i think which
even though you are not tagged formally
as as one but i think in one sense or
the other you wear something on that
line right a research software engineer
i mean a computational phases on one
hand
but also a research software engineer
because of the very nature of the work
that you're doing very very fundamental
level but there are proper research
software engineers not many of their of
their breed but uh
i think it's a growing breed uh
so
what kind of role do you envisage for
them in the academic world in the
industrial world
it's always dangerous to make
predictions especially if it's about the
future some wise fans say that
can you define what the research
software engineer is these are the
people who would be part of a larger uh
scientific project but their main job
would be to develop the codes
uh
which would be much much better written
than a professor or
uh
on inexperienced hand that
coding would be
so maintaining
respect some of the more traditional
production quality standards of software
development
but in a research setting
i see yeah
i i guess that was the group i was
working on that atlanta was one of most
of our tasks where or a lot of the
people in the group
um
were maintaining the large physics codes
and implementing new methods and like
numerical methods even doing basic
research but but most of the or like
maine i would say focus was on
developing new methods and maintaining
and speeding up the current methods as
well as making sure the codes run on
modern hardware and
and get good performance and so on um so
if that's the task of our research yeah
i mean um so your question is would i
see as a future of this
branch
yeah and i think um
you always need to
be that's that's thinking more along the
lines of so suppose this uh there's some
guy who because of some experiences uh
that he has grown up with during his
undergraduate masters uh
he joins a research group here his main
utility to the research group is is
along that line as a research software
engineer and he spends now maybe four
years five years in that group publishes
papers along the island because he has
been contributing to the code
but then uh he graduates one day and
then maybe he gets a a great job as a
postdoc also because that kind of skill
is
really really
highly required
but
when it comes to an academic position
when it comes to an academic position if
the uh if the only strength he has to
show is on the numerical side or maybe
on the on the software development side
of things uh
and and every question that uh what was
the scientific
initiative that you took for that he has
to pass the bug to his line manager or
to some collaborator that he's worked
with and never something that he has
started on his own i know it's a
contentious question but uh
yeah so what do you think that would be
a
wise decision
i see okay so i guess it's a question
about the career
exactly
well then i would say you just have to
decide what you want in a career like
what's
what do you want to do
so and then then you go from there so in
my case i wanted to after uh finishing a
phd i wanted to work in
i wanted to do some basic research as
well as computational physics and work
with
people who do that and really learn a
lot and publish
and also
so i was looking at positions like these
and of course i i did as i mentioned
before i really enjoyed working at the
lab
i used to work at livermore too i think
i worked there for about eight months
and great people there i think all the
national labs in the us are are awesome
from this perspective and i collaborated
with people at from lba lawrenceburg lab
in sandia and oak ridge
it's just great you know great
environment and i really enjoyed that
kind of environment so if that let's say
you would like to get into an
environment like that
well then um
you apply for well there's multiple ways
to get in i went through the postdoc
route so you apply for postdocs so to
get so let's say the question is how do
you get accepted as a postdoc uh well um
so you have to uh i think
people are looking for the skills that
you have some publications so that comes
back to during your phd publish
something show that you know how to
program it's good to maybe have some
projects i think either your own or i
think it's fine if you contribute to
other projects as long as you can show
what the contribution was if you
implemented some new method or or maybe
spread out the code or maybe ported the
code or whatever maintenance you are
doing if you can show what it is and i
think that's that's great
um
and then
yeah once you get in as a postdoc then
um it's much easier to get a job as a
staff as there are white tech i took
because once you get in i came with the
advice out of the way once you get in as
a postdoc to any lab and so on
um make a lot of friends a lot of calli
like a lot of get to know a lot of
people let's see what we work on and
then
as you get connected you know use the
two years to kind of get well connected
and
then typically you can find either
opening or uh some ways ways to get get
in
so that's that's the route i took
yeah
okay so i mentioned just before we
actually started this uh
video recording uh about uh that little
uh incident uh
with uh professor neil ferguson's uh
kovitzen code uh we are not fully out of
the pandemic yet so it's probably
relevant that we talk about it so so for
people who don't know uh
a lot of the policy uh
that was done in the uk was uh i think
at least up i don't say a lot but a part
of the policymaking was done based on
our discussions with his team professor
neil ferguson's team and uh based on the
research that they had done and they
actually ended up making the code the
kovid sim code uh public and when it was
made public uh
proper professional software engineers i
mean they had uh very very negative
things to say to put it mildly about
that code
saying that it was a mess and whatnot
and there was a lot of back and forth
and
more trained people who had seen
both the sides of academic research
and the professional practices
they they gave a more nuanced thing so
as i was mentioning dr conrad hinson
from france he he gave a very nuanced uh
argument for and above the various
nuances of it uh and so so what what is
your take about these things so so
people who are developing these kinds of
codes
from scratch on a blank file and then
over years and years maybe 5 10 15 years
some big code develops and then it is
for wonderful better word mess
which would not actually happen in a
real professional software engineering
team
do you see any way out for this
maybe there's a bigger role for research
software engineers as we are just
discussing earlier
uh
yeah i mean i've seen a lot of calls but
i don't claim that i know how to develop
anything like that but
my own view on this is that uh first of
all i've seen large teams developing
terrible codes also so it's not in just
the fact that you have a team of uh of
you know of very good people it doesn't
mean that you know you
deliver on a delivery usable code um and
the reason is that once the call becomes
big it's actually um
uh it requires quite a lot of i would
say experience designing it so that and
ensuring that as as people especially if
you have a larger team of people
contributing to it that it doesn't
become a mess because i think my
experience at least is that almost by
default you can assume that any big code
becomes a mess so for example with the
alpha trunk compiler it's
a compiler is a huge huge task and so
it that's why every compiler is a mess
because simply because it's a big code a
lot of people contribute to it and
oftentimes what happens is that people
contribute a little fix
and they don't have the time to
understand the code and so they just
want to fix some particular thing and
they do their best but it's for others
to maintain the fix and so
you know so that's that's for compiling
now the
the scientific codes um
so it depends who develops it uh but
oftentimes it's the same thing so let's
say a student wants to implement some
new method or some new feature but
you know they do and they they do their
best and then they leave and so somebody
else has to maintain it and so it
depends on who is in charge of the code
and to keep
making it maintainable now coming to the
covet code i forgot exactly
if it was it uh just a single person
code
sorry say that again
a single person write the code mostly no
no so uh it was his entire team i think
they had developed the code
over many many iterations and they had
applied that same code so so this code
was basically our translation of the
actual research work on the on the kovid
model so he's a mathematical biologist
professor neil ferguson developed by a
professor and his students yes exactly
that's a lot of quotes like that and so
i'm not gonna comment on this particular
code because i don't remember
the details but what i've seen with
other goals developed like that so you
have a typical let's say a professor at
the university and has students so the
students help with the code and
contribute my thoughts and new research
and so on the prophecy typically doesn't
even have time to really work on it even
though he would like but no time and so
this students working on it and he you
know at best maybe he kind of manages
the design a little bit but you know you
you just kind of
patch it up and then the student
develops it for let's say two three
years then they gradually leave next
student
different skills different styles so it
just becomes a part work of things it's
just inevitable it's just the way it
works and so
um
i guess the question is or maybe your
question is is there a better way to do
it
yeah so so can we perhaps incorporate
some kind of formal training as part of
like you wouldn't want a student to
write an fm food without first
actually formally learning the fem
algorithms so
why not why not
in terms of the practice of writing good
also
so i think um yeah so i think um well
what i'm trying to say i guess is that
i've seen many many codes like that and
they all kind of look the same and for
the reasons i described
but i've also seen other codes i guess
if the profit if the person who maintain
a professor if they don't let the design
out of their hands and so to say kind of
keep
i guess
reviewing the pull requests and making
sure that
you know
the design is good and then they have
good test suit and a good kind of
engineering practices for the code i
would say
they have a continuous integration uh
solid test suit that they spend good
time andre
i have to uh i have to interject here a
little bit you mentioned something like
a pull request
uh i would be very very surprised if
uh a majority of the mechanical
engineering professors or chemical
engineering professors or civil
engineering professors would be even
familiar with a thing like version
control
so i guess what i'm trying yeah okay so
i'll explain it uh but
so you know historically let's say
when i did my phd
with uh so my um
professor was
a physicist and a lot of the physicists
and
you know in the 80s there was no you
know
like they did their best you know back
then the computers were a lot slower and
also these kind of modern development
practices were not as um you know known
even or like you know people were just
figuring out how to maintain these how
to develop and how to maintain these
things and and significant competing is
also a little bit of a special branch of
of these things because we care about
performance and accuracy and these kind
of things and i would say it's really
amazing that uh if you look at some of
the older codes that they even work and
not not only they work they are accurate
and fast and you know they have bugs but
maybe it's really messy inside but they
deliver on the things that truly matter
which is the performance and accuracy
and get the job done and implement very
complicated numerical methods and
physics methods and so on and so
it's
and so you cannot do everything i guess
and so if you are good at physics and
good at
you know understanding the methods and
are actually able to program them and
actually deliver you know it that can be
all that there that you can do but i
think the modern approach to developing
these codes in my opinion is to have
some of the mobile engineering practices
and so and if you use them and i'll
describe what they are
i think it helps really keeping the code
much more manageable and so what they
are i think is to use some kind of a
platform like github or gitlab or
bitbucket
that that
control system
and
again 20 years ago there were like five
of them now it's just one it's called
git
and
it it keeps every comment every every
time you you develop a new feature you
develop it in a set of comments each
comment you can think of it as a patch
there's a change to the source code it's
a series of comments you submitted to
that let's say github as a pull request
so the way it looks like it it's kind of
like a proposed change and then a person
somebody else can go in and review your
changes either individual comments or
and then
if and and then of course it should run
a test suit automatically uh so that you
know the professor is busy all he has to
do is come in and see the pulley request
change and see that the test suite runs
he reviews that no changes were made to
the test suit then and then the review
the changes and then he clicks one green
button and then merges the change to
master
romaine i guess a lot of people call it
may now so one main branch and and there
you go so
and i can you know we can talk more
about the workflow you can look it up
online it's called pull request based
workflow
um continuous integration means that the
test runs automatically uh that your
test students automatically uh online
and so
that's part of it that's kind of the
technical part and social part oh and
also when you review the pull request
you comment on the individual changes
and once you get into this um kind of
workflow that already prevents all kinds
of um
it improves the codes because first of
all when you submit the code and you
actually see the change that you're
proposing you yourself don't want to
write to mexico because it looks messy
and you know um
as a professional you like to submit
your job in a clean and nice way you
don't have to be embarrassed about it so
you know certain level and so this
encourages that kind of its kind of
feelings and so as opposed to if you
just thanks for pointing that out
actually so i've been maintaining a
github code since i mean
a few github repos
most of which are private because i'm
too embarrassed to make them public but
i have noticed this thing that you just
mentioned that even for those private
repositories i don't want to embarrass
my future self
so i take care a little bit more than i
used to and for my coursework for the
for the few repos that are public uh the
students uh use them uh i certainly take
a lot of care
uh i think and i think it's a wonderful
wonderful way this this version control
thing i i didn't know it like five years
ago
but uh i'm getting familiar with it but
i think there's more uh do it on the
social side of things so the so the
people uh the professors i think uh and
i'm not talking about computer science
professors so professors in the physical
sciences so if they start getting to see
the benefits of actual version control
and things like github uh probably they
they will try to enforce it in their own
groups and that will bring about a sea
change in how things are done
so so is it perhaps possible to make a
layman's uh introduction to github like
the kind of fortran pages that you have
started generating like i love those
pages of portrait i mean are so very
impressed so uh absolutely targeted at
layman users like me uh so if we can
have something which is along those
lines for uh for better software
practices software engineering practices
are targeted at research scientists i
think it will be a wonderful wonderful
step forward and i don't know if it
already exists in some form
i think there are some i think this is a
known problem i think kondra hinson
doesn't he describe
kind of these kind of workflows on his
blog post on his blog yeah
i think there are a lot of a lot of
resources for for this
it's
you know as i mentioned i think the
hardest thing is that if you are a
professor at university or maine
especially
modern age your main
time is spent uh chasing uh grants and
writing grants and
and then all kinds of busy work so you
don't really have time for this you know
and so it's kind of tough to there's
always a million fires to put out every
day
that's right and so it's it's uh you
know i'm not you know
i guess and i think i can't remember
what kundalini wrote about that that
code that you mentioned the covet code
but you know it's easy to
complain how messy it is but you know
you
uh you could have written a better goal
you know and at least at least he has a
code that you know maybe
he has a code at least
it's not the best but at least there is
a coach right so you know
but i think in general yes i think the
what i like
what i think helps is if it's open
source because that
just automatically puts you in the
spotlight and you don't want to put the
message over nobody wants and so that
automatically just brings the code
quality up uh the review pull request
reviews uh having a good test suite
those are the basic things
and continuous integration just having
these things helps and also uh what also
helps is to package your code as a
library or application in some kind of
either conda or spec or even pip
essentially some some package manager
because that puts you in know
[Music]
it essentially you'll stop you you have
to look at your code from the
perspective of a user who actually has
to install it and you realize oh our
build system is fragile and this doesn't
work and it doesn't work
but if you do all these things um that
all automatically brings your code up um
you know
[Music]
big time so i think that's the solution
i think there are there's a minority of
professors out there in the modern age
so closer to my age uh probably a little
bit senior
who are uh doing their uh i mean quite a
bit of work on this and and there's a
journal of open source software and uh i
think uh professor lorna barbara she's
doing an incredible work uh in this
regard
uh
so yeah so just like we have scientific
papers so also we have scientific papers
surrounding the development of the code
and this is all open source software so
i mean
it's it's not
huge but it is growing i think
yeah yeah no the i haven't actually
published there but i i know about the
general yeah
okay so uh all right so now we come to
the most important question
what is your work set up like what what
what
uh system you use which editor you use
do you have any special workflow which
helps in your productivity
so i sorry uh
that was just a lightweight movement
it's a good question i use i used to use
linux for the last maybe 20 years but
lately i actually i don't know how i use
a mac because i like the the m1 you know
the apple m1 max they're really fast the
cpu is really really fast and so it to
give you an example it uh i had the
latest intel
desktop machine
at
leno and uh
it uh you know a lot of money and so on
and you know very latest and it compiled
um
in maybe 16 seconds and then um
my wife's we bought this cheapest you
know third for 13
for 1 300
you know this apple and one
and it compiled a fortran at the same
time so how's that even possible you
know like
so so this is just you have to see it to
believe it but yeah i timed it i counted
side by side even i clicked enter on
both you know i log into my computer
network and then
on the local terminal i hit enter at
both and i finished
so
yeah so anyway and then
so right now i have the apple and one
back that's even faster so it compiles
it in about 11 seconds for 12 seconds so
anyway so i i just like this speed so
much and ultimately and regarding the
rest i'm actually even with you i was
using ubuntu and i guess i was not
really
you know one thing i learned is that if
you start customizing the desktop too
much then you come to a new computer you
have to customize everything else so i
just kind of use the stock ubuntu no
customizations i use a terminal obvious
for most of my work and i have my like
dot
the dot files you know for with the
configuration but for the same reasons i
try to keep it very simple so i use a vm
as my editor or new vm i guess
um
and um
and gate so i have a git config file but
that's it i think those are the two main
config files lately i started also use
to use vs code which is an editor ide i
guess
um but so i use
veim and vs code and so on the mac i
still use vm and vs code and a terminal
and i don't use anything else so
for me the workflow just doesn't change
and if i use windows i would do the same
thing i would use vs code i will use a
terminal
i think windows has a like this nice new
terminal uh so i would use that and i
would use vein also so i can use any
operating system i guess
okay good to know so i was using uh
wayman a bunch of open source software
on windows uh and every time i had to
tinker with it a little bit i had to
look up online and all the help was from
the linux guys so actually i was putting
in more effort in windows trying to get
them to work so i thought that what the
heck let me just move over to linux
it'll be easier maintaining them and i
have been doing it so this particular
recording is being i mean i'm on ubuntu
24. so
yeah there we go
all right
so uh from your very early days you have
been heavily informed uh involved with
free and open source software uh except
this recent uh
uh use of apple m1
so do you have any message to the
student community who was similarly
involved
in free and open source software
yeah um
you know just find an open source
project that you like and then
contribute it so
[Music]
i guess like on the broader scope uh the
just let's say
doing senpai even though i did not find
funding directly for it
it has in a way
opened the door for me for all of my
jobs
it helped me get to the phd because i
got
so the way i got to the us is that i
started senpai and then one of the
contributors
i realize he's from the czech republic
where i was so i met him and then he met
this professor at some conference and he
told me hey you should you should email
him and
that's how i got to the us as uh
to do my phd to do a post doc um i
um
i guess you know through senpai i meet a
lot of people or they they hear of me or
get to know me and so it just opens the
doors and that's
the most important things to to you know
to progress your carry to get the jobs
that you like and so
so so contributing to open source uh can
help with that because it um
you get to know a lot of people and um
and your work because it's open source
you can put it on your cv and they if
you are interviewing somewhere they can
look up what you did exactly um and and
you know you almost don't need anything
else if you have good open source work
behind you whether your own project
sorry contribute some other projects
listed on your cv and um
it
you know like like like when i
let's say interview people whether for
post dogs or students and
you know if i want to know you know
what their skills are if i can see their
open source contributions i don't need
to know anything else because i can see
the discussions you know we talked about
pull requests so so that's the
communication is big part of it so i can
see the discussions the communication
everything is there and so you know it's
just kind of it's
it's just a great way to
um
if you don't have many connections it's
just a great way to to get those
connections and and improve your cv
and correct me if i'm wrong since you
mentioned cv i have been telling a few
of my students
that look if you keep on using windows
and stuff around windows that's not
something that you can actually brag
about in your scene because nobody cares
you're supposed to know that anyway but
suppose you start using linux and uh
some of the open source software and
maybe you you think around with a little
bit then that's something you can
actually put on your cv you can brag
about it carries a little bit of weight
maybe not not the
not like a published paper
but uh
it it's something better than just using
windows so in a very materialistic sense
also it's probably uh using f uh free
and open source offered pays
uh in these kinds of softwares
yeah i guess i guess you're right
as i mentioned i've used linux for 20
years so for me that's kind of normal
this is default i guess but you're right
that i guess uh
uh if you don't use linux at least learn
how to use a little bit uh it's it's a
it's a linux it's kind of like fortran
linux or unix in general has been around
for
you know yeah
40 back of the remember
since 70s i guess so long time
and what's interesting about it is that
it's still here today even the mac is is
based on uh unix based on
the b is one of the bsd i can't remember
which one which is you know from unix
and so the the philosophy of unix which
is uh we just have a kind of
program for one task and have a
system structured you know around the
terminal and
um it's uh it's it's just you know it's
a i would say
time proven you know methodology that
that works and so
if you don't use linux definitely learn
and learn it a little bit um so that you
know how to use it yeah so well i had a
little bit of experience with linux as
an undergraduate student uh just a very
very little bit i i use it much more
nowadays and back then so you know so
maybe 10 years 15 years ago it was not
as
user friendly as it is now and it keeps
on becoming more and more user friendly
so and we were behind a proxy in our
campus uh so to to get get get the
ethernet working you had to use
something i think it was called the
samba protocol or something like that
uh
i learned that by fiddling around with
it then one of my seniors came back from
his postdoc with his apple uh with his
mac
and uh he just couldn't get it to work
behind the proxy so he asked me to take
a look and i had never touched a macbook
before that was my only time i actually
touched one uh and i and i saw that that
was a problem he was not using so i just
typed his smb in something something and
just started working
yeah so there you go it's just
it it teaches you that the operating
system is not a black box but it's
composed of these little programs and so
on linux source code follow all of it
and so it's very nice to
just learn you know especially if you
have the time you can dig into all those
codes you can read the source codes i
did yeah you know i guess i've done all
this at high school it's a long time ago
i haven't really done it too much since
but yes i you know i recompiled the
kernel and i read the source code and
bash and i wanted to know how that works
and i wanted to know the init scripts i
wanted to know how the system boots so
look you can look up in the kernel
exactly the first line the assembly line
gets executed by the buyers so you can
like say oh this is how it starts the
32-bit you know both and it switches to
64-bit stuff like that so it's all there
and then and then the kernel is finished
and then it launches the the first user
space program so you can learn again how
it all works it's nice you know it's
good to know and there is not more to it
that's all there is to it and so knowing
you know how this all works it helps i
think it's just really interesting but
yeah just
think of it on windows you cannot see
because you don't have the source code
so
[Music]
we really don't have many things in
windows
uh all right so uh
uh
so i'd like to ask uh something on a
more personal note what kind of books do
you read so
so technical non-technical section
non-fiction so give it a go i would like
to i used to read a lot but i don't have
the time because i have three young kids
and so besides my work and and you know
open source here and there i don't have
the time for anything else
yeah
i haven't read books i guess
i had a lot of books in high school and
before that but uh at university i had
to focus obviously you know the school
and after that it's always something so
i don't read too much let me ask you
what do you read
well uh
i i read uh religiously one uh author of
his
um
uh his doctor amitav
uh
so
he's a he's an indian author but he
writes in english uh absolutely
gorgeously beautiful english so so i
like his stories as a fiction writer but
he's also uh heavily invested in writing
stories around climate change uh so
building stories around that uh i really
like that
i sometimes read some
some non-fiction
i was reading this
biography of
humble the the german scientist
so the invention of nature
i think it was by andrea wolfe uh it
want a bunch of awards but it's a
beautifully written book uh
and some some some books around history
maybe sometimes philosophy but then i
feel sleepy and
i close the book
but i don't find so much time honestly
speaking uh yeah it's hard uh
okay so final question uh
so uh i mentioned this in the earlier
part of our discussion that
the languages the the natural languages
that you speak as human beings it
affects our thoughts and there's a lot
of research going on
in that aspect
and
there's even a movie made about it uh
arrival uh
so so these aliens come and they
uh and these scientists they try to
communicate with it and uh in the
process of trying to communicate they
learn the language this lady this this
this scientist she learns the language
and the language itself is such that uh
it it allows you or maybe it unlocks
that that i mean it's a science fiction
okay so it it unlocks that
that power in her brain to see the
future
uh
so it's it's an exaggerated version of
what is going on but there is maybe some
truth to it so in a similar vein do you
think that programming languages
could unlock different
abstractions in our brain or different
aspects of our brain
to
problem solve in different ways
yeah i would say no doubt uh for i would
say for sure uh to give one example of
this is that
say for the sun if you're competing
let's say i spend a lot of time yeah
yeah
so
if you use a language it doesn't have a
race say i've done a lot of a lot of
i've written you know as a you know
during high school
um written a lot of coding pascal
doesn't it doesn't have very it has 1d
arrays but not
multi-dimensional arrays and so
without the arrays it's if if you've
never heard of them or never use them
then you don't even know you're missing
them and so you just kind of do what you
can and then you learn a language like
python and number and even then it's
like you know because i wasn't used to
thinking in terms of it is so numpy
allows you to do arrays but you know i
never use it kind of never quite
understood why why would i use
multi-dimensional arrays and then
i learn fortran and that's kind of the
basic ingredient there of the language
and that's what you use for everything
and then you realize oh i can i can use
it to structure i can structure my
algorithms to operate and i can store
the data in multi-dimensional arrays and
i can use the indices so for those of
you who don't use arrays i can explain
it very simply you have the array and
you don't think of it you have a 5d
array so you don't try to imagine if
idea you just use these indices to the
array to store information so for
example let's say you do some finite
element method and you have quadrature
in 3d so you use first and that says
cartesian product just to make it simple
so you have three indices quadrature in
x y and z and let's say you have
multiple uh solutions
well you have an element typically so
you do fourth index element and let's
say you have multiple solutions multiple
orbitals or whatever that's the the
fifth element so there you go save the
five the array and you saw every index
so once you kind of start thinking in
those terms you suddenly realize oh
almost every algorithm can be written in
that approach
and it turns out that it's also very the
the compilers are regularly optimizing
that kind of code
and so that that you know and so that's
a part of the language so i think it's
just one example that if you have it and
you learn how to use it it just opens up
it just completely changes how you think
about writing algorithms so now so after
learning that now when i when i write
algorithms i always figure out
what data i have uh how to store it um
i have to figure out uh the order of the
indices it matters how it you know
depends on how you access the array so
it depends on the algorithm you want to
access the array in the fortran always
the leftmost index first so the
innermost loop always has to have the
leftmost index first as the fastest
in c
it's exactly the opposite is the
rightmost index and numpy by default is
the right most index i think i'm
actually not sure i haven't as you can
see i haven't written too many
performance critical coding now by
itself not by allows for turning c order
i just don't remember right now to be
honest um which order is the is the c is
the default but i don't know the order
of the arguments but in fortran yeah
it's always like stick continuous and so
anyway once you learn these little
tricks it just opens up
you know a lot of possibilities
so i'm sure
we don't know what else we are missing
so we see fortran we have the array so i
know we want that but what else do we
want uh and i'll tell you we have it and
have some experience with it we don't
know what we are missing and so i think
no doubt
we are i would say with parallel
features i think uh software has
parallel rays but i feel there is more
that can be done on the language level
in terms of parallelism but until we
have it it's hard to um you know have to
know what we are missing but i think
it's another example that things might
change a lot in the future if
language is uh become you know as they
introduce these features it will just
enable all kinds of
easier programming
so i would say yes
thank you uh so regarding the
multidimensional areas so people like us
who have to spend professional time with
dancers i think uh
it's a it's a very
it's a comfortable world out there which
i i think i'm missing out on uh
because i'm not using program but we
have this to a certain extent in other
languages but uh i think it lends itself
naturally to that kind of thought
process uh people who think about tenses
and and uh as theoretical faces i think
you can appreciate it much more than i
do
so the entire
the the einstein's index notation
you keep on just putting on the
subscripts
and then you have a nice very structured
mathematical way of condensing the
entire thing
uh
without losing your mind
yeah and i guess i'm used to using
tensors in the physics sense which are
so it's about the transformations and
the bases and coordinate bases and so on
so it's a coordinate free representation
of the equation yeah
but the amount of dimensional arrays i
like to call them arrays because it's
just it's just a set of numbers but it's
just
it's just a convenient way of organizing
the
instead of instead of storing every you
know what i describe with the example
instead of storing it as separate arrays
or not even erase at all sometimes it's
it's just competition it's it's uh
easier well it might sound more messy to
just store everything in one array or a
couple arrays but it but if you do it
well first of all it's extremely
performing because the data is
contiguous in memory and the compilers
can really do a good job optimizing it
but also it's actually simpler to read
also because the code is just kind of
shorter
and you still use the indices to
distinguish between different things um
so it's just for perform and and you
have to do it anyway for performance
code even if you don't want to think of
it as a multi-dimensional array you want
to have the data in memory in a
contiguous way and you need to be able
to access it
in you know optimize the access system
so you might as well use
multi-dimensional arrays it gives you
structure to the code so i think
it's not really that complicated uh do
you think that
uh of like physical objects having uh
multiple degrees of freedom they could
be encoded in this way probably it's
already done i i'm not experienced
enough you know
are you thinking like like pendulums or
like yeah
yeah
yeah so yeah so if you do um if you want
to store the coordinates so it depends
how you depends what coordinates you
choose but uh whichever way and not just
the code as well uh the information that
you need for uh for each point so maybe
the velocity and the
position so all of them together in in a
bunch of together as a multi-dimensional
array
if you write a molecular dynamics code
so yeah so you store all the particles
in the array
all the coordinates and the speeds and
then uh you know to the array like
one index is the xyz dimension and the
second index particularly
yeah but you have to do that
all right so i think uh uh by the way i
didn't ask you about your uh your recent
a new job uh congratulations about that
uh you are now in are no longer in los
alamos
uh gsi technology you want to end this
discussion with a little bit of uh
description of work that you're doing
so i really want to finish this for
trade compiler and so
i think i don't know if it's because
most people are these big you know
companies are moving away from fortran
or what it is but it was hard for me to
get funding i did find some i was very
happy about it about uh
30 of my time
um and i'm very grateful for that um
but i really wanted to focus 100 on this
and so i
found this company called gsi technology
it's a hardware company they develop
chips
and they
[Music]
they they're mainly
their business uh is selling memory
chips but they also recently started
developing their own
actual like
computational chip computing in memory
and it's much faster than this gpu for
certain tasks and so but it has a very
peculiar their own you know new
architecture and so they wanted to make
it easier for people to program and so
they have a compiler team
and they
liked the fortran design and so i
decided to join them and so we are now a
compiler developer full-time working on
using the fortran
middle land and the back end
they don't mind fortran but you know as
we discuss python is the most
kind of the first language that needs to
work and so we are also writing a python
front end to the same
middle end that l4tram uses and so
i'm now working pretty much on the on
this compiler on this compound
technology full time and so i'm very
excited about it it's um
and also we have funding for uh students
so if any of you are interested uh
listening and if you are interested in
working with us let me know just contact
me uh
uh we have something that you are
interested in working with do you mean
in the form of internships
internships and you don't even have to
be a student now but yes internships
[Music]
and other opportunities i i believe our
students would love this part of the
conversation
[Music]
all right okay so so let's uh let's end
this discussion on this very positive
note very helpful note uh thank you
andre for spending your time i have
overshooted well is this not even over
shooting this is this is massively
overshooting at the time but thank you
so much indeed